gesagt von den Oppositionsparteien
gleich beginnen wird wir sehen die
beiden Ausschussvorsitzenden Michael
grosse-brömer den Vorsitzenden des
Wirtschaftsausschusses von der CDU und
Klaus Ernst von der Linkspartei eher
führt den Klima und energieausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages an beide
Ausschüsse haben sich nun also gemeinsam
versammelt und anders als vor zwei
Wochen wird dieser Ausschuss nun
öffentlich stattfinden Kameras sind
diesmal zugelassen das haben die
Ausschussmitglieder heute morgen
entschieden können wir rein
abzuwickeln wobei das gerade in dem
heutigen Fall auch gar nicht so einfach
war das soll ja auch jetzt gesagt sein
ich begrüßte sie natürlich auch im Namen
meines Kollegen Klaus Ernst der auch
gleich noch das Wort bekommt aber wir
haben heute einen einzigen
Tagesordnungspunkt ist ein Antrag der
cdu/csu aber auch ergänzt durch einen
Antrag der Fraktion DIE LINKE dabei
handelt es sich um den
Tagesordnungspunkt weitere Aufarbeitung
der Stellenbesetzung ist Vorsitzende der
Diener Geschäftsführung sowie aktuelle
Berichterstattung zu möglichen
Compliance Verstößen und zur
Personalpolitik des Bundesministeriums
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und es
handelt sich um den Bericht des
Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz für aktuellen
Berichterstattung über mögliche
Interessenkonflikte in der Leitungsebene
des BMW Karber Industriepolitik
Außenwirtschaftspolitik digital
wir haben
bevor wir
inhaltlich anfangen kurz darauf
hinzuweisen dass es bei nicht immer der
Terminierung und nicht bei der
Öffentlichkeit dieser Sitzung aber bei
dem Ablauf dieser Sitzung
unterschiedliche Auffassung gab ganz
konkret zwischen
Opposition und
Regierungskoalition das darf man glaube
ich einleiten und sollte man auch
einleitend erwähnen
mehr Kollege ernst und ich waren sehr
dafür dass
befragungsformat der letzten Woche auch
heute anzuwenden mit
entsprechenden runden vier Minuten
fragemöglichkeit für die einzelnen
Kollegen wir haben gestern einen
Schreiben bekommen
aus der Fraktion die der Grünen das
heute nicht wie in der letzten Woche
dieses befragungsformat auch einzeln mit
der direkten Befragung durchgeführt
werden soll sondern so wurde es dann
auch entsprechend Bean in unseren
gemeinsamen Ausschüssen
das jetzt gefragt gesammelt werden
sollen und nicht mehr vier Minuten Zeit
dafür besteht sondern nur noch eine
Minute das heißt wir können jetzt danach
nicht mehr direkt jemanden befragen
sondern wir sammeln jetzt von allen
Fraktionen jeweils Fragen die dann auch
geschlossen beantwortet werden ich
wollte ich will das vielleicht einleiten
sagen ich habe da die Wortmeldung
gesehen von dem Kollegen jung
das Herr Kollege Meiser hat sich auch
gemeldet ich will nur einen Geist sagen
dass wir das auch im
Wirtschaftsausschuss und soweit ich weiß
auch im
parallelausschuss auch was die Abläufe
des der heutigen Sitzungen betrifft
diskutiert haben auch mit Blick auf die
Geschäftsordnung des Bundestages ich
sollte erwähnen dass eine erste Prüfung
ergeben hat dass man wie immer auch
unterschiedliche Interpretationen
durchführen kann das aber keine
offensichtliche wie heißt das rechts
keine offensichtliche Unzulässigkeit
dieses Beschlusses gibt insofern werden
wir als Vorsitzende die wir Wert darauf
legen müssen dass die Sitzung
ordnungsgemäß abläuft dann auch diese
Beschlüsse so wie sie gefasst sind dann
jetzt auch umzusetzen haben also statt
vier Minuten werden wir jetzt dann
lediglich eine Minute lang die Fragen
haben und dann nicht direkt sondern
einzeln
gesammelt und nicht einzeln sondern
gesammelt so ist der Beschluss der
beantragt wurde von der Ampel und dafür
gab es auch eine Mehrheit in den
jeweiligen Ausschüssen ich darf das
glaube ich sagen dass der Kollege
ernst und ich nachdem wir gestern davon
Kenntnis von dieser Änderung erlangt
haben auch die ob Leute angeschrieben
haben und mitgeteilt haben dass wir das
für eine
inakzeptable Beschränkung der
fragemöglichkeiten halten
das ist unsere Auffassung das wird
das haben die Beschlüsse gezeigt in den
jeweiligen Ausschüssen jedenfalls von
den Fraktionen der Regierung
oder der regierungstragenden Fraktion
anders gesehen und deswegen ist es so
beschlossen worden
das nur mal einleitend zu dem bisherigen
Verfahren ich habe jetzt Wortmeldungen
dazu von dem also vielleicht der Kollege
Ernst noch als Ergänzung dazu bevor wir
dann die Wortmeldung die wir haben dazu
aufrufen ja ich wollte jetzt noch sehr
bedauernd alles Verfahren deshalb beim
letzten Mal gewählt haben eigentlich ein
sehr effektives und ausführliches
Verfahren war und vor allen Dingen dazu
geführt hat dass die Fragen auch einzeln
beantwortet wurden die gestellt wurden
das ist jetzt schwieriger wir werden das
so verfahren aber ich glaube wir beide
werden dann auch darauf achten weil es
ja sechs Fragen hintereinander sein
werden die gestellt werden dass auch
jede Frage beantwortet wird und
gegebenenfalls auch noch darauf
hinweisen dass vielleicht noch eine
Frage offen ist so dass ein einigermaßen
vernünftig ist Verfahren dann gemeinsam
hinkriegen genau das ist dann auch im
Interesse aller
ja ansonsten hoffe ich dass wir das
wieder genauso vernünftig durchführen
können wie beim letzten Mal und wir
können dann ähm Michael die
entsprechenden
einsteigen ja soweit ich das gesehen
habe habe ich jetzt die Meldung der
Kollegen jung Meiser und allem
Andreas Jung bekommt das Wort ja sehr
geehrte herrenvorsitzende liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Robert Habeck
hat in der vergangenen Sitzung in
unserer gemeinsamen Ausschusssitzungen
auch im Plenum erklärt dass er bereit
ist öffentlich umfassend zu allen Fragen
hier redet und Antwort zu stehen in der
letzten Sitzung war es dann aber so dass
die Mehrheit der ampelfraktion gegen die
Öffentlichkeit gestimmt hat diesmal
wurde unserem Antrag auf Öffentlichkeit
entsprochen sie wollen aber das Frage
recht beschneiden des fahrgericht ist
ein parlamentarisches kernrecht ich
teile und meine Fraktion teilt
ausdrücklich ausdrücklich die Auffassung
der beiden vorsitzen dass wir genauso
wie wir es in der letzten Sitzung
gemacht haben heute wieder Verfahren
sollten vier Runden mit vier Minuten mit
der Möglichkeit den Minister und die
Staatssekretäre direkt zu befragen Frage
und Antwort sie wollen stattdessen
allgemeine Debatten runden der
Fraktionen keine direkten
sie wollen statt vier mal vier Minuten
in vier Runden wollen sie eine Minute
das sind 75% weniger Zeit als das letzte
Mal also sie wollen die sie wollen die
Zeit ganz erheblich beschneiden und sie
wollen die direkte fragemöglichkeit
nicht zulassen damit beschneiden sie
parlamentarische Rechte wer für
Transparenz stehen möchte der muss für
Transparenz Stimmen ich stelle für
unsere Fraktionen Antrag dass wir
dieselbe Verfahren wählen wie in der
vergangenen Sitzungswochen vier Runden
mit vier Minuten pro Aktion mit der
Möglichkeit direkt zu fragen direkt
Antworten zu bekommen
wir müssen dabei berücksichtigen dass
wir in den jeweiligen Ausschüssen schon
abgestimmt haben aber es kommt der
Kollege Meiser der das Wort hat
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender
Ziel der heutigen Sitzung so habe ich
alle Fraktionen verstanden sollte ja
sein für größtmögliche Aufklärung und
Transparenz zu sorgen Sie begrüßen wir
als Link auch ausdrücklich dass die
heutige Sitzung anders als beim letzten
Mal öffentlich stattfindet umso
unverständlicher ist mir allerdings auch
warum die Ampelkoalition mit ihrer
Mehrheit heute hier durchsetzen will
dass das beim letzten Mal bewährte
Verfahren dass ein Abgeordneter in der
Wahrnehmung seiner parlamentarischen
Kontrollpflichten und Rechte im Minister
und die Staatssekretärin nicht direkt
befragen und direkt Antwort darauf
bekommen kann ich habe auch in den
Debatten die wir ja schon hatten dazu
kein einziges Argument gehört warum das
sich beim letzten Mal nicht bewährt
haben solle der einzige Unterschied
heute ist es öffentlich und ich meine da
stellt sich doch die Frage warum tun sie
das also ich würde sagen sie schließen
sich ein großes Eigentor aber warum
warum tun sie es denn ist denn da also
sie erwecken doch den anscheinend sie
hätten mit der direkten Frage und
Antwort ein Problem oder Herr Minister
Habeck oder die Staatssekretär hätten
ein Problem damit ich habe beim letzten
Mal nicht den Eindruck dass ihm so war
darum tun sie das heute so ich kann es
einfach nicht nachvollziehen direkte
Frage direkte Antwort das wäre der
richtige Weg deswegen unterstützen wir
auch den Vorschlag der Unionsfraktion
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender auch ich
möchte für meine Fraktion ja das
Unverständnis ausdrücken über diesen
Wunsch der ampelfraktion in einen neuen
Modus überzugehen der eben nichts zur
Aufklärung beitragen wird wir haben in
der letzten Sitzung ein gutes Verfahren
gehabt das hat dabei geholfen dass wir
Fragen beantworten lassen konnten dass
wir Nachfragen stehen konnten direkte
Frage direkte Antwort und in einem
solchen Fall wo sich eigentlich doch
alle die Transparenz auf die Fahnen
geschrieben haben sollte es ihm auch
genau so stattfinden weil wir alle
wissen was passiert wenn wir Fragen
sammeln und es werden viele Fragen sein
das Fragen hinten runterfallen dass wir
keine Nachfragen stellen können die sich
auf eine konkrete Antwort beziehen und
so kann es nicht sein so dürfen wir uns
die parlamentarischen Rechte der
Abgeordneten nicht beschneiden lassen
deswegen stellen auch wir den Antrag das
wir zum Modus des der letzten Sitzung
zurückkehren weil nur dann eine
ordentliche Aufklärung Transparenz
möglich ist
ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
die Wünsche absolut akzeptabel
allerdings war sie ja nun so dass wir in
unseren jeweiligen Ausschüssen genau
diesen Gegenstand abgestimmt haben und
es ist so dass nach der Geschäftsordnung
bei Ausschüssen die gemeinsamen Tagen
alle Gegenstände die zu beschließen sind
in den einzelnen Ausschüssen zu
beschließen sind nachdem in den
einzelnen Ausschüssen beschlossen wurde
wer eine zusätzliche Abstimmung hier aus
meiner Sicht nicht akzeptabel weiß ja
schon entschieden ist ich würde deshalb
ich würde deshalb bitten dass wir jetzt
die ich glaube die Meinungen sind auch
gut ausgetauscht unabhängig davon wo wir
unsere persönliche Prioritäten haben
haben wir gesagt bin auch sehr
bedauerlich dass sie so läuft aber dann
sollten wir jetzt wirklich in die
Befragung einstellen jetzt haben wir
aber noch mal eine Wortmeldung von
Kollegen jung ja Vorsitzer ich möchte
doch darum bitten dass hier abgestimmt
wird so haben wir es in der vergangenen
Sitzung auch gemacht mit derselben mit
derselben Geschäftsordnung
nein es ist nicht rechtswidrig es ist
hier eine Sitzung bei der zwei
Ausschüsse zusammenkommen und es ist in
der letzten Sitzungswoche gelungen eine
Abstimmung zunächst des einen
Ausschusses und eine Abstimmung dann das
anderen Ausschusses ist ja beizuführen
und ich möchte schon bitten dass hier
öffentlich das möchten Sie ja vermeiden
in der nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen
haben sie diese Anträge abgelehnt und
jetzt in der öffentlichen Sitzung
möchten Sie noch nicht mal dazu Stellung
nehmen ich stelle fest es gibt keinen
einzigen der jetzt ein berlines Argument
dagegen vorgebrachte sie möchte noch
nicht weiter dazu stellen erklären Sie
uns bitte warum möchten Sie Fragen
Antwort nicht zulassen Robert Habeck ist
dazu bereit er das ist letzte Mal nicht
nur gemacht er hat das letzte Mal die
Bereitschaft erklärt und sie möchten
noch nicht mal dazu Stellung nehmen sie
möchte noch nicht mal dazu abstimmen ich
beantrage dass es getrennte Abstimmung
der beiden Ausschüsse zu unserem Antrag
gibt
also der Hinweis dass die ja schon
stattgefunden haben in den Ausschüssen
natürlich richtig ich habe jetzt zwei
Wortmeldungen die Kollegin badum für die
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und der Kollege
coming für die AFD und dann würde ich
auch empfehlen dass wir dann vielleicht
auch die Zeit nutzen um dann in die
Befragung einzusteigen so
naja auch wenn ich mir eine andere hatte
Befragung wünschen würde
nutze ich das nutze ich jetzt wo ich
gerade Beifall bekommen habe ja also die
Kollegin Warnung wo ist sie da
bitteschön
ich stimme Ihnen völlig zu wie sollen
die Frage Runde einsteigen es ist ein
bewährtes Verfahren sozusagen Debatten
Runden zu machen das kennen wir alle
darf ich kurz Ausreden bitte das können
wir alles aus unseren Ausschüssen es
wird Frage und Antwort geben und die
Vorsitzenden werden selbstverständlich
nachhaken wenn Fragen auch nicht
beantwortet sind wir haben hier für
völlige Transparenz gesorgt diese
zumindest öffentliches über den
Livestream erhältlich alle Ihre Fragen
können heute geklärt werden und deswegen
schlage ich jetzt vor dass wir in das
Verfahren entsprechend noch einsteigen
der Kollege kommen bitte
ja vielen Dank vielleicht noch mal
abschließend aus juristischer Sicht
bisher wurde immer politisch
argumentiert und auf das auf die
Transparenz abgestellt ich habe es
vorhin schon in Wirtschaftsausschuss
gesagt wir haben eine Geschäftsordnung
diese Geschäftsordnung gilt zunächst man
kann von dieser Geschäftsordnung
abweichen wenn sich alle darüber einig
sind dass davon abgewichen wird
wenn sich nicht alle einig sind darüber
dann gilt die Geschäftsordnung Punkt und
dann kann nicht darüber abgestimmt
werden wie ein Prozedere das in der
Geschäftsordnung festgelegt ist wo im
übrigen auch die Minderheitenrechte der
Oppositionsfraktion berücksichtigt sind
die da kann die Geschäftsordnung nicht
mit einer Mehrheit des Ausschusses
einfach außer Kraft gesetzt werden das
geht so nicht das ist rechtlich nicht
zulässig deswegen nochmal die
Abstimmungen sind von so verlaufen dass
kein Einvernehmen hergestellt wurde und
deswegen gilt die Geschäftsordnung und
deswegen muss aus meiner Sicht auch so
der Ablauf dieser Sitzungen verlaufen
mir die Geschäftsordnungen es vorsehen
nämlich unter Berücksichtigung der
Minderheitenrechte anderenfalls das ist
mein letztes Wort anderenfalls könnte ja
die Mehrheit des Ausschusses einfach
sagen auch die Opposition die kriegt nur
20 Sekunden
Sorgerecht ja das geht aber auch nicht
deswegen gibt sie Geschäftsordnung mit
der Beachtung der Minderheitenrechte
danke
ich glaube wir haben ja auch in
Wirtschaftsausschuss der ausführlich
darüber diskutiert und ist ja auch
deutlich geworden dass ich von dieser
Argumentation
eigentlich auch sehr viel halte aber
eine überschlägige Prüfung dieses
Beschlusses hat ergeben dass keine
offensichtliche Rechtswidrigkeit besteht
insofern ist das auch so weit geklärt ja
wenn es Bedenken gibt ich bin nun auch
Jurist genug und ich war ja auch mal als
Notar tätig also vielleicht glauben sie
mir dann müssen wir jetzt weil wir ja
auch irgendwann zu Befragung kommen
wollen mit all den vorbehalten die es
rechtlich auch weiterhin geben wird und
die ich teilweise auch Teile dann müssen
wir das nachträglich überlegen welche
Auswirkungen das haben kann ich schlage
nur vor dass wir jetzt wenn auch mit
einer verkürzteren Zeit und in einem
anderen Format dazu kommen die
Bundesregierung zu befragen wenigstens
das sollten wir jetzt machen auch wenn
die Opposition geschlossen sich wünscht
dass wir das in einem anderen Verfahren
in einer längeren Zeit hätten
durchführen können das ist jedenfalls
mein Vorschlag jetzt und deswegen haben
wir das sowohl in den Ausschüssen wie es
im Übrigen in der Geschäftsordnung dann
vorgesehen ist jeweils entschieden mit
Mehrheit durch die Ampel das ist jetzt
zu sein soll wie es ist in Abweichung zu
der wie ich finde auch guten
Vorgehensweise in der letzten Woche die
dann nicht öffentlich war aber wie auch
immer ich denke wir kommen jetzt mal
dazu dass wir auch in die Befragung
eintreten und deswegen
wird es so sein dass wir dann jetzt eine
Minute lang jede Fraktion die
Möglichkeit hat eine Frage zu stellen
und wir machen dann jeweils eine Runde
der Fraktionen durch und dann wird
entsprechend geantwortet wir beginnen
bei diesen zwei Runden abwechselnd mit
den Mitgliedern des
Wirtschaftsausschusses und kommen dann
zu dem Mitglieder des Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz in Energie vorher wenn es
gewünscht wird würde ich dem Herrn
Bundesminister noch das Wort geben für
eine kurze Einleitung falls das noch
erforderlich ist
und dann beginnen wir mit den Fragen
die hervorsitzenden sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen ja ich würde gerne ein Aspekt
der ja doch sehr breiten Titelgebung
rausarbeiten ein Aspekt nur weil ich
sonst zu lange reden würde und ich
möchte Ihnen gerne politisch
einordnen oder kommentieren und das ist
der Aspekt von
Finanzbeteiligung beziehungsweise
möglichen Interessenkonflikten alle
anderen Fragen Patrick reichen Diener
und so weiter dann natürlich gerne in
der bewerten Dialog Runde erst einmal
möchte ich sagen dass
dass ich froh bin dass Politik nicht nur
im eigenen Saft schwimmt und das ist
gelungen ist an verschiedenen Stellen
nun auch bmwk mit Udo Philipp ein
Wirtschaftsexperten einen erfolgreichen
Manager zu gewinnen noch einmal Zeit und
Nerven und Kraft für das Gemeinwohl
aufbringen zu lassen und in die Politik
zu wechseln seine Expertise Kenntnisse
der Märkte Kenntnisse von Unternehmen
Kenntnisse von Mittelstand Kenntnisse
von Start
Maschinen helfen denke ich bei der
Erneuerung von Wirtschaft und Wohlstand
aber der politische Punkt dahinter ist
dass wir uns fragen wollen ob Menschen
die in der Wirtschaft tätig waren dann
auch in der Politik ihren ihr Wissen
einbringen können ich würde das bejahen
sonst in der Tat Kreiseln wir am Ende
wir die vielleicht nicht diesen
Hintergrund haben nur noch um uns selbst
das begrüße ich also sehr und freue mich
dass du Philipp diesen Weg gegangen ist
ich möchte kurz nur kurz darauf
hinweisen was der Rechtsrahmen für
Finanzbeteiligung oder Finanzgeschäfte
insgesamt ist zu nennen ist einmal die
marktmissbrauchsverordnung der
Europäischen Union die verbietet Insider
Geschäfte und Markt Manipulation wie
jede Verordnung geht es detailreich
weiter aber das ist sozusagen der
allgemeine große Rechtsrahmen neben dem
Dienstrecht für Beamten dort ist zu
nennen Einschläge der paragraph 61 der
sagt dass das Amt nach besten Wissen und
Gewissen uneigennützig zu führen ist
dann gibt es eine Reihe von konkreten
Ausarbeitungen und Hinweisen für die
Bundesregierung da hat sich meiner
Kenntnis nach in dieser Legislatur
nichts geändert das heißt also das bmwk
damals BMW arbeitet entlang der
Compliance Verordnung Vorschriften
Leitfäden der alten Bundesregierung die
immer federführend von bmi also dem
Innenministerium ausgearbeitet wird und
dann natürlich für die anderen Häuser
gilt
umgesetzt werden sie dann jeweils in
Schulungen in Handreichungen in den
Häusern individuell auch die
referatsaufstellung in den Häusern
Compliance Referat wie bei uns im
Ministerium vorhanden erfolgt dann
entlang der Aufstellung des Hauses da
hat sich in meinem Haus seit der
Amtsübernahme vor wie viel 16 17 Monaten
formal nichts geändert diese
Rechtsnormen sagen alle das
Interessenskonflikte zu vermeiden sind
und die definieren über die
verschiedenen juristischen Ausfüllung
Interessen im Grunde so dass
dienstliches Handeln nicht dem von dem
einen privaten Interesse geleitet werden
darf das ist also die Frage die heute
dann im Raum steht
dienstliches handeln darf nicht von
einem privaten Interesse geleitet werden
das wäre dann sozusagen das was verboten
ist in den verschiedenen Ausformulierung
sie sagen wiederum nicht dass man als
Beamter oder als Mitglied eines
Parlament ist sich nicht in Fonds oder
im gesellschaftlichen engagieren darf
noch nicht mal sagen sie das ist
anzeigepflichtig ist oder transparent
gemacht werden muss und das hat Udo
Philipp getan er hat also mehr getan bei
Amtsantritt und dann jetzt auch in der
Nachfragen als eigentlich diese Normen
vorgeben
der politische Punkt auf den ich hinaus
Steuern wollte ist dass wir wenn wir
politische Entscheidungen treffen
natürlich immer auch Entscheidungen über
die Wirtschaft oder über wirtschaftliche
Perspektiven treffen und dass uns das
allen Bewusstsein muss und wenn man das
in Frage stellt man über die
Regelsetzung insgesamt reden darf ich
möchte ein paar Beispiele nennen von
verschiedenen die Handelspolitik häufig
diskutiert jedenfalls in
Wirtschaftsausschuss eröffnet
Unternehmen neue Markt Zugänge
logischerweise wenn man Fonds hat sind
in den Fonds Aktien diese Aktien bilden
Unternehmen ab und diese Unternehmen
mögen davon profitieren wenn wir den
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds
aufstellen bei Corona oder auch in den
Zeiten danach beispielsweise die
lufthansarten aber einen Vorgang aus der
letzten Legislaturperiode mag es sein
dass Abgeordnete oder Beamte oder
Staatssekretäre in der letzten
Legislaturperiode Fonds hatten in die
Lufthansa drin war wenn wir über
Gesundheitspolitik oder
digitalisierungspolitik diskutieren mag
es sein dass Fonds Aktien von
Unternehmen drin sind die davon
profitieren wenn wir die Ukraine
militärisch unterstützen mag es sein
dass in irgendwelchen Fonds auch Aktien
von Rüstungsunternehmen sind die davon
unterstützen davon profitieren ich will
damit also sagen die Rechtsnorm wie
unser tätiges Handeln führt zu diesen
Fragen logischerweise die Frage die im
Raum steht ist aber ist unser Handeln
geleitet von der privaten interessens
Wahrnehmung das ist die Frage die
beantwortet werden muss und für Udo
Philipp ich hoffe das können wir in den
Befragungen dann klar machen kann ich
sie dann klar verneinen
ich will für
meine Seite gerne sagen dass wir wenn
uns das nicht reicht die Regeln
überprüfen können gegebenenfalls
anschärfen können es gibt andere
Beispiele das Europäische Parlament und
die Europäische Kommission hat weit
strengere Transparenzvorschriften auch
für die Abgeordneten wo dann die Fonds
öffentlich gemacht werden müssen oder
jedenfalls für die Kommissionsmitglieder
die französische Regierung oder die
französische Kultur schreibt vor das
nicht nur Anteile an Finanzen sondern
auch privates Vermögen also Häuser
Wohnung und private Schuld öffentlich
gemacht werden muss denn es mag ja auch
Interessenkonflikte dagegen der viele
Wohnungen hat macht möglicherweise
beeinflusst sein wenn es um
mietpreisbremsen geht wer
Eigentum besitzt oder erwerben will mag
möglicherweise beeinflusstsein davon
wenn es um Grunderwerbs
besteuerungsfragen geht und wer private
Schuld hat das ist vielleicht der größte
Moment wo man denken kann na ja da kann
es ja eine Abhängigkeit geben
der Markt möglicherweise auch dort eine
Art Befangenheit haben ich will damit
sagen wenn wir das Gefühl haben dass
diese in der Natur der Sache stehende
interessens
Überschneidung weiter aufgeklärt werden
muss dann lassen Sie uns über Regeln
Verschärfung reden dann allerdings über
regelverschärfung für alle für alle
Ministerien für alle die davon betroffen
sind für alle die sich im Parlament
fragen müssen ob sie der Transparenz
Genüge führen was ich nicht richtig
finde ist hier ein ein Einzelfall
Beispielen nur weil ein Staatssekretär
in diesem Fall aus der privaten
Wirtschaft in die Politik gewechselt ist
zu dieser Diskussion bin ich gerne
bereit danke schön
herzlichen Dank Herr Minister für diese
einleitenden Worte und dann kommen wir
jetzt zu der ersten Frage Runde es
beginnt für die SPD ähm während
Westfalen vielen Dank Vorsitzender gut
dass wir jetzt zum Zweck der Sitzung
kommt so Aufklärung von Sachverhalten
der Staatssekretär Philipp und auch das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium haben die
Beteiligung an einigen Fonds
veröffentlicht meine Fragen sind hatten
sie Kenntnis bezüglich der Förderung
eines der Unternehmen nämlich African
green Tech welches mit mehreren 10.000
Euro durch das Ministerium gefördert
worden ist zweitens waren sie bei der
Förderentscheidung beteiligt drittens
welche Rolle hatten sie bei der Berufung
von Mitgliedern des Beirates junge
digitale Wirtschaft im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
insbesondere bei der Berufung von
Sebastian Böhmer in dessen Fong first
Momentum Venture sie ebenfalls
investiert haben und haben sie letzte
Frage haben Sie aktiv für den Beirat im
bmwk diese Person empfohlen herzlichen
Dank das waren 48 Minuten der Vorsätze
genau also das ist fast also es ist
fast bewundernswert wenn wir das jetzt
noch so machen dass man Einzel fragt und
Einzel antwortet weil ich glaube das
hatten wir jetzt anders entschieden so
wir müssen jetzt am Anfang immer klar
machen wie immer die Frage stellen wenn
ich das richtig verstanden ging das
konkret an Staatssekretär Philipp genau
dann hat jetzt das Wort Julia Klöckner
für die CDU CSU danke schön meine Fragen
gehen auch an Staatssekretär Philipp und
Sie müssen jetzt schnell mitschreiben
ich händige in die Fragen auch aus damit
keine untergeht erstens im bankblock
haben Sie Herr philipp am 18 März 2018
einen Beitrag veröffentlicht Zitat ich
komme aus der Finanzwirtschaft ich war
sozusagen eine der größten Heuschrecken
in Deutschland und hier werden Klima und
Finanzindustrie plötzlich zu Partnern
meine Frage an Sie sehen Sie keinen
Konflikt dass sie heute für die Themen
zuständig sind bei denen sie selbst in
Wester sind zweite Frage wurden sie vor
ihrer Ernennung zum Staatssekretär von
bmwk auf mögliche interessens
Konflikte hingewiesen drittens wann und
in welcher Form haben sie das BMW K über
ihre privaten Beteiligungen und
Investitionen informiert viertens wen
haben Sie über Ihre privaten Beteiligung
und Investitionen dann genau informiert
5 wusste der Minister davon wenn ja wann
und in welcher Form sechste Frage
nachdem sie seine oder eine Beteiligung
oder ihre Beteiligung gegenüber dem bmwk
angegeben haben ist genau was passiert
haben Sie eine schriftliche Reaktion des
bmwk auf diese Anzeigen erhalten und
wenn ja welchen Inhalt siebtens jetzt
kriegen wir das ist jetzt natürlich so
jetzt hätten wir vielleicht nur drei
Minuten aber jetzt haben wir nur eine
gehabt dann müssen wir die nächste Frage
in der nächsten Runde Stellen 40 darf
ihn vielen Dank damit nichts untergehen
bitte das ist aber nicht ja so die
Kollegin Netze hat jetzt das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
guten Tag herzlichen Dank Herr
Vorsitzender ich bin froh dass wir die
Anhörung nach dem bewährten Verfahren
des Wirtschaftsausschusses durchführen
können die Diskussion hier meine Frage
richtet sich noch mal auf die
Neubesetzung der Stelle des
Staatssekretärs die jetzt
dankenswerterweise sehr schnell
vollzogen wurde nach dem Ausscheiden von
Patrick reichen der Nachfolger ist ja
der Staatssekretär jetzt im hessischen
Wirtschaftsministerium
nimmermann wir haben viel diskutiert
über die Frage wie werden auch welche
Kriterien werden herangezogen um
zentrale stellen auch im bmwk zu
besetzen und deswegen möchte ich an
dieser Stelle dieses Diskussion noch mal
lenken auf die Frage an den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister welche
Kriterien wurden für die Berufung von
Herrn
angelegt und was war bei der eigenen
entscheidend herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin jetzt kommt
für die AFD vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzende
meine Fragen gehen an Minister Habeck
die Afrika greentec hat ja Fördermittel
bekommen in 2022 aus dem bmwk wie ist
das mit den Vorgaben zur
Korruptionsprävention des bmwk zu
vereinbaren nachdem ja schon der
anscheinend vermieden werden muss für
Vorteile empfänglich zu sein
vor der Berufung von Sebastian Böhmer in
den Beirat junge digitale Wirtschaft
sind sie dort bereits informiert worden
das Herr Philipp Anteil an einem Fonds
zu dessen Gründern Sebastian Böhmer
gehört
dritte Frage warum hieß es zunächst
gegenüber der pressestaatssekretär
Philipp habe keine Kenntnis über diese
Förderung von Afrika greentec wie
erklären Sie sich das
nächste Frage können Sie ausschließen
dass der neue Staatssekretär Philipp
nimmermann überfangen und
Firmenbeteiligung oder Beziehungen zu
Organisationen verfügt an die Aufträge
von bmwk vergeben wurden und wenn ja auf
welcher Grundlage danke
perfekt in der Zeit jetzt zum Abschluss
der ersten Frage Runde passt
ach ja zwei noch da war doch noch was
also es kann doch nicht sein dass ich
die FDP übersehe doch offensichtlich
schonervorsitz ich bitte mehrfach um
Entschuldigung das will lieber Herr
Kollege rufen sie haben das Wort für
eine Minute die herrenvorsitzenden Herr
Minister ich habe eine Frage an
Staatssekretär Philipp nach
Pressebericht da der Leiter der
wärmeabteilung Christian Maas nach
eigener Aussage alle seine Anteile am
hamburg-institut das Konzepte für die
Energiewende entwickelt verkauft die ja
vor seiner Zeit im Ministerium führte
das wären Maß ein besonderer Maßstab
oder ein anderer Maßstab als für sie
gilt liegt nach Aussagen des bmwk daran
dass das hamburg-institut im Kern den
Themenbereichen von Herrn Maßen
entspricht aus meiner Sicht betreffen
aber auch die Beteiligung von Ihnen Herr
Philipp den Themenbereich Startups wieso
wurde die Gefahr eines
Interessenkonflikts dennoch anders
bewertet als Bayern Maas und warum haben
Sie persönlich nicht auch die Konsequenz
entsprechend gezogen wie ein Maß und
ihre Beteiligung verkauft
vielen Dank
Pascal Meiser jetzt abschließen für die
Linke
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender ich habe
drei sehr konkrete Fragen an Herrn
Staatssekretär Philipp
zunächst ganz generell halten Sie es für
problematisch oder für unproblematisch
wenn ein Unternehmen an denen sie als
Staatssekretär direkt oder indirekt
beteiligt sind von den Entscheidungen
ihres Ministeriums wirtschaftlich
finanziell profitiert
zweitens Herr Philipp könnten Sie bitte
hier noch mal für alle abschließend
darlegen
an welchen Unternehmen sie tatsächlich
beteiligt sind direkt oder indirekt
Ausweis sich dessen was man lesen konnte
sind sie ja auch an diversen Fonds
beteiligt die aber ja nach meiner
Erkenntnis unmittelbar auch in konkrete
Unternehmen investieren und es wäre der
Transparenz wegen glaube ich für alle
wichtig zu wissen über welche
Beteiligung wir in Gänze hier sprechen
um den Vorgang beurteilen zu können und
das letzte können Sie ausschließen das
außerhalb des bekanntenfalls Afrika
greentec noch weitere Unternehmen in
denen sie mittelbar oder unmittelbar
beteiligt sind von Entscheidungen des
Ministeriums wirtschaftlich profitiert
haben Dankeschön und ich würde jetzt
vorschlagen dass die meisten Fragen
gehen ja an den Herrn Staatssekretär
dass er dann beginnt mit den Antworten
und ich glaube der Minister wenn sie
dann ergänzen weil das war ja dann ich
würde gerne Verlauf
in der hierarischen Reihenfolge bleiben
und kurz kurz anfangen wenn sie davon
Wert legen können Sie das gerne machen
dann betrifft es ja nur eine Frage
glaube ich die an sie gestellt wurde
also nicht dass wir jetzt auf alle
Fragen antworten wenn Sie mir glauben
ich wollte nur vermeiden dass ihr auch
noch auf Fragen an den Philipp antworten
weil dann hat die Zeit wir sind ja
sozusagen bei dem Fragezeichen auch
schon ein bisschen eingeschränkt worden
es wäre schön wenn man nicht bei den
Antworten dann auch noch doppelte
Antworten bekommen das darf ich sagen
was ich sagen möchte aber 100%ig zu dem
was sie gefragt wurden würde ich
vorschlagen
dann erst einmal ich habe den
derzeitigen Staatssekretär nimmermann in
Hessen nach der Trennung von Patrick
reichen gefragt ob er sich vorstellen
kann nach Berlin zu gehen weil er ein
nach Bestätigung seiner bisherigen
Minister und auch nach dem was ich weiß
über ihn ein Mann ist der Prozesse sehr
gut strukturieren kann weil er ein
zugänglicher Mensch ist weil er sich
schnell intim einen arbeiten kann weil
er schnell zur Verfügung steht er ist ja
schon im Staatsdienst weil ein sehr
erfahrener Verwaltungschef ist und ein
guter Kenner von Energie merken und mit
der Laub hervorsitzender ich möchte
gerne zwei Fragen denn noch mit
kommentieren weil sie von relevant sind
die erste Frage da möchte ich gerne auf
mein eingangsdatmen verweisen noch
einmal es ist erlaubt
und ich würde sagen die Bundesregierung
will ja gerade eine aktienrente
einführen sozusagen auch noch gewollt
dass Beamte Fonds haben das heißt es
gibt gar keine Anzeigepflicht davon und
ich müsste es auch so formulieren am
Ende stimmt auch die Legislative immer
wieder darüber ab welche Unternehmen
gerettet welche werden welche Politiken
wir fortsetzen die Frage von
Interessenkonflikten stellt sich nicht
nur für Staatssekretäre im
Wirtschaftsministerium sondern genauso
für andere Beamte und deswegen
sowohl auf die Fragen die Udo Philipp
bei Anzeigepflicht
Veröffentlichungspflicht und Interessen
Kollision
gestellt worden ist diese Frage
juristisch und compliance-rechtlich
beantwortet die Leitfrage muss sein gibt
es einen privates Interesse dass
dienstliches mit privaten Philipp gleich
antworten und die zweite Kommentierung
die ich gerne machen möchte betrifft den
Beirat junge digitale Wirtschaft weil
vielleicht nicht ganz bekannt ist was
das für ein Beirat ist es ist ein Beirat
der 2013 geschaffen wurde der Mitglieder
beruft für immer ein bis zwei Jahre also
es ist keine dauernde Mitgliedschaft der
seit 2013 83 Mitglieder hat der derzeit
29 Mitglieder hat die dabei hat ist rein
ehrenamtlich er kriegt keine
Aufwandsentschädigung keine Gelder er
hat eine rein beratende Funktion und
organisiert sich selbst in diesem Beirat
sind verschiedene Akteure und mir war es
wichtig mir war es wichtig dass gerade
weil wir da ein extremes Finanzproblem
haben das aus den start-upszenen heraus
Gründerinnen und Gründer dabei sind und
vor allem auch Stream studentischen
Milieu hinaus denn das werden sie
politisch einordnen können da haben wir
viel Wissen aber wir können es nicht in
wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit häufig genug
übersetzen deswegen wussten meine
Staatssekretär und die Banden im Haus
das meine Vorgabe war sucht dort Leute
die auch
Unternehmensgründung aus den Unis
Bauhaus machen können und Udo philipp
hat dann Namen genannt dazu gehörte dann
auch Herr Böhmer Herr Böhmer ist seit
fünf Jahren startup-gründer ein Student
für Studenten inzwischen nicht mehr
Student aber es ist eine studentische
start-up-firma wenn Sie so wollen für
Studierende und diese Expertise haben
wir an keine anderen Stelle gefunden
deswegen fand ich es eine gute Idee und
ich habe das Ding hier am Ende
abgezeichnet eine gute Idee dass diese
Expertise ebenfalls vertreten war soweit
von mir vielen Dank Herr Minister Herr
Staatssekretär Philipp sie haben jetzt
das Wort
okay dann
versuche ich das mal nach sozusagen
besten besten Kenntnissen Gewissen zu
machen also die erste Frage von Herrn
Westfalen hatte ich Kenntnis über die
Förderung der Afrika GreenTech ich hatte
keine Kenntnis darüber die das Licht
daran dass ich mit der Entscheidung das
war die zweite Frage im auch nicht
befasst wurde das wiederum nicht daran
dass Entscheidungen dieser Art also
sprich Förderungen von kleinen
Unternehmen im nicht politisch von
Staatssekretärin entschieden werden
Staatssekretäre entscheiden über
Förderrichtlinien mit aber die einzelnen
Förderungen werden von Projektträgern
gemacht und gehen nicht in die
politische Leitung des Hauses hoch
in diesem Fall wurde das war es eine
Energieförderung die Sie angesprochen
haben die die selbst wenn sie
hochgegangen wäre wäre sie nicht zu mir
gegangen aber wie gesagt sie ist auch
nicht in die Leitung gegangen die ist
vereinfachlich entschieden worden zu der
Frage der Berufung von von Herrn Böhmer
hat der Minister ja bereits alles gesagt
Herr Böhmer ist der erste oder ist einer
von von fünf Personen die den ersten
studentischen Venture cable Gefahren
gegründet haben und das ist der Grund
weshalb er in diesem Beirat mit drin ist
dann würde ich zu den Fragen kommen die
Frau Klöckner gestellt hat die
sie haben mir gesagt ich hätte eben
Komma aus der Wirtschaft sozusagen und
ich habe mich in der Tat einmal selbst
ironisch als Heuschrecke bezeichnet wie
Sie wissen kommt diese Bezeichnung sie
wissen von wem die kommt und die die ich
habe aber das ist der Grund weshalb ich
in die Politik gegangen eben in meiner
Zeit bei einem großen private Deck für
die Form eben wirklich sehr viele Dinge
miterlebt ich war mitverantwortlich oder
teilweise auch wirklich alleine
verantwortlich dafür dass in Unternehmen
investiert wird dass da wirklich sehr
stark in die Zukunft investiert wird und
dass dort auch viele Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen worden das ist etwas wo ich
wirklich auch heute noch stolz darauf
bin ich bin habe da natürlich aber auch
andere Dinge gesehen Dinge die ich nicht
so gut fand und insbesondere wie manche
Unternehmen mit dem Staat viel Geld
verdienen können und ich habe mir gesagt
ich möchte gerne in die Politik gehen um
die Dinge die ich dort gesehen habe auch
einzubringen und das ist mir wichtig und
wenn sie dann eben sagen es gibt da
gibt's manche Kenntnisse wo wo diese und
sie besonders komisch finden also was
was ich was dass ich jetzt für Startups
zuständig bin kann ich nur sagen es ist
richtig dass ich als Staatssekretär im
bmwk federführend für die Startup
Strategie zuständig bin das ist aber
auch etwas was ich für wichtig halte ich
halte es für wirklich ausgebrochen
wichtig Frau Glöckner dass wir eine
starke dynamische gute Startup-Szene
haben in der wir endlich mal mit der mit
dem Aufschließen zu dem was die USA
machen und da bin ich wirklich mit
Herzblut dabei und und das ist etwas wo
ich wirklich keinen Interessenskonflikt
sehe ganz im Gegenteil dann wurde ich
vor meiner Ernennung zum staatstekäfer
vom bmwk auf möglichen
Interessenskonflikte hingewiesen es gibt
selbstverständlich ein Begrüßungspaket
wo alle Dinge drin stehen ich kann ihn
aber sagen ich habe ich glaube es war
ungefähr eine Woche bevor ich ins
Ministerium ging dass die Compliance
Abteilung also um genau zu sein die
Zentralabteilung des Ministeriums in
denen dann irgendwo dann auch das
Compliance Referat ist kontaktiert und
habe darauf hingewiesen dass ich und
dann direkt Unternehmensbeteiligung habe
dass ich an Fonds beteiligt bin und dass
ich Aktien halte die über sogenannte
vermögensverwaltungsmandate sozusagen
verwaltet werden und ich habe gefragt
wie ich mich damit auseinanderzusetzen
habe und da habe ich eine klare Antwort
bekommen die Antwort hat der Minister
letztlich gerade geschildert nämlich das
worum es geht worum es überall geht wenn
es wenn es um Interessenskonflikte geht
ist die Vermeidung von Insiderregeln das
haben wir in das sind Dinge über die Sie
als Bundestagsabgeordneter in den
Gesetzen entscheiden und die wir dann
auch umsetzen mit Richtlinien und so
weiter und so fort und die da kann ich
Ihnen sagen genau eben zu Vermeidung von
Insider auch nur den anscheinend von
irgendwelcher in von irgendwelchen
insider-konflikten das ist genau der
Grund weshalb ich meine Anlagen im so
halte wie ich sie halte in Fonds oder
eben die Aktien über ein sogenanntes
vermögensverwaltungsmandat wo die Bank
eben von mir ein bisschen Geld gekriegt
hat und die dafür eben die Aktien kauft
und das was dort wirklich wichtig ist
und deswegen gibt es eben auch kein
Interessenkonflikt das ist bin nicht ich
derjenige der entscheidet ja nicht ich
entscheide welches Unternehmen gekauft
wird nicht ich entscheide was mit dem
Unternehmen passiert
sozusagen wenn es mal gekauft wurde
nicht ich entscheide wann es gekauft hat
und ich entscheide auch nicht wie lange
es gehalten wird und wann es wieder
veräußert wird und deswegen gibt es hier
eben auch kein Interessenkonflikt und
deswegen sind die Dinge so geregelt wie
sie eben geregelt sind und die die dann
war ihre Frage was mein Minister davon
wusste ich bin mir nicht mehr wirklich
ganz sicher was sie ihm gesagt habe ich
bin sicher dass er wusste dass ich aus
der Wirtschaft komme viel verdient habe
und und ihn in
die Anlagen habe die im private Deck für
die Bereich oder in Aktien sind
die die
Reaktion habe ich ihnen gerade gesagt es
gab eine Reaktion das war so die Frage
habe ich denke ich beantwortet so dann
komme ich zu den Fragen mit von von
einem Holm
ich müsste den Anschein schon vermeiden
dass es bei AGT ein Interessenskonflikt
geben könnte ich habe ja gerade gesagt
die ich war bei bei
ich habe als ich ins Ministerium
gegangen bin
von Tag eins eine Sache sichergestellt
ja ich mit den Unternehmen mit den vier
Unternehmen an denen ich beteiligt bin
bin war und werde ich nicht befasst sein
ja das ist mir wirklich wichtig ich war
damit nicht befasst ich bin damit nicht
befasst und ich werde damit nicht
befasst und deswegen genau deswegen gibt
es auch nicht den Anschein dass ich dort
irgendwo ein Interessenkonflikt haben
könnte
dann war die Frage zu Herrn Böhmer die
ist ja bereits beantwortet ich möchte
dann noch mal einmal ganz deutlich sagen
Herr Böhmer ist einer von 29 und und ist
ehrenamtlich so wie alle anderen auch
ehrenamtlich sind da gibt's auch keine
aufwandspauschalen und nichts und die
dir ist es Stimme in diesem Beirat also
eine von 29 und der Beirat ist eine
Stimme in einer Stakeholder Konstruktion
zu Konsultation über machen als wir die
start-up-strategie gemacht haben haben
wir ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wie
viel ich glaube fünf aber ich lange sie
mich nicht fest ob es genau fünf waren
Stakeholder runden gemacht und wirklich
die unterschiedlichen Stakeholder und da
waren dann immer viele Leute am Tisch
mehr haben lange Workshops mit denen
gemacht und wir haben lange angehört und
zusätzlich haben wir im natat auch noch
den Beirat angehört und deswegen ist das
glaube ich hierzu alles gesagt dann
kommt die Frage von einem Huben die und
die die haben sie ja ein Teil der
Antwort wirklich selber ja schon gegeben
herum Herr Maas war beteiligt an einem
an einem Institut dass das wirklich ganz
maßgeblich sich ausschließlich mit den
Dingen beschäftigt die Herr Maaß macht
bei mir ich bin beschäftigt ich bin an
Unternehmen direkt beteiligt davon ist
wenn man genau das sich anguckt eins
davon ist ein Startup und dieses eine
was ein Startup ist ist in Frankreich
das hat ein guter wirklich guter
französischer Freund von mir gegründet
den ich wirklich sehr schätze der ist in
Deutschland nicht tätig er hat in
Deutschland auch ich würde gerne ich
meine ich wüsste gar nicht ob es
irgendein Programm gäbe für französische
Firmen ja aber der ist auch noch nie auf
die Idee gekommen in Deutschland nach
irgendwelcher Förderung zu verlangen das
andere Unternehmen über das was wir hier
schon X jetzt x mal gefallen ist Afrika
greentec gut sie können sagen es ist
Startup als einigermaßen junges aber es
ist Social und das ist das ist ein
Sozialunternehmen da geht es ist nicht
ein Profit maximierendes Unternehmen das
macht das versucht unter in Afrika die
Dörfer die nicht ans Netz angeschlossen
sind mit Solarindustrie zu versorgen ich
weiß nicht ob die jemals Gewinne gemacht
haben seitdem ich dort beteiligt bin wie
mir sehr sicher dass nicht den Vers hat
es nie eine Dividende gegeben und die
anderen beiden Unternehmen sind kleine
Mittelständler die durch die sozusagen
Dinge machen die der eine ist eine
Softwarefirma und das andere ist eine
weiterbildungsfirma da habe ich nichts
damit zu tun dass ich da irgendwie für
zuständig wäre und wie gesagt ich kann
das nur noch mal wiederholen bei allen
vier Unternehmen ist sichergestellt dass
ich damit nicht befasst war nicht
befasst bin und auch nicht befasst sein
werde und dann die die wesentliche Frage
die sie gestellt ja warum hat er denn
nicht verkauft ja also die eine Antwort
ist es gibt keinen Grund zu verkaufen ja
die zweite Antwort ist glaube sie weiß
gar nicht genau ich habe indem es auf
dummerweise nicht angeguckt aber ich
gehe mal davon aus dass sie aus der
Wirtschaft stammen und Sie werden
wahrscheinlich wissen was es bedeutet
einen ein Minderheitsanteil ja von vier
fünf sechs oder ich glaube einmal 8%
oder sowas zu haben an einen ein einer
kleinen GmbH wie einfach ist das Herren
ein Minderheitsanteil an einer kleinen
GmbH zu veräußern ja das ist ich glaube
ich brauche ihn das nicht zu erklären
wie schwer das ist und
deswegen habe ich das bislang nicht
gemacht es gibt einfach keinen Markt für
Minderheitsanteile an nicht an der Börse
gehandelten Unternehmen und das das ist
wie soll man sagen ja die ich ähm ja ich
glaube ich habe die Frage beantwortet
dann dann
kommen wir
zu Herrn Meiser er ist es
also ich glaube da habe ich das meiste
auch schon gesagt es ist die die ich
sehe nicht warum wo ein Unternehmen an
dem ich direkt beteiligt bin von meinen
Handeln profitieren sollte ich habe ihn
habe das ja versucht zu erklären ja wir
haben dort klare klare Spielregeln wie
das funktioniert die die Dinge die dort
entschieden werden wenn in der Regel von
Projektträgern entschieden die Sachen
kommen nicht zu mir hoch wenn sie zu mir
hoch kommen gibt es kommen sollten wie
gesagt ja es ist in der ganzen Zeiten
das muss man vielleicht auch noch mal
sagen ist sind jetzt anderthalb Jahre
vier Unternehmen da ist nichts schief
gegangen ja ist ja nicht irgendwie so
dass irgendwas schief gegangen wäre und
nicht irgendwie aus versehen was
unterschrieben hätte ist nicht passiert
ja und wenn dann doch irgendwas
hochgekommen wäre in meinem Büro ist
sichergestellt dass das die Dinge dann
nicht mehr vorgelegt werden dann ist es
fragen sie ob ich alle meine Fonds
offenlegen sollte und da möchte ich noch
mal einmal ganz ganz deutlich sagen der
hat der Minister ja mehrfach jetzt in
seinem Eingangsdaten und dann danach
noch mal gesagt
dass Menschen Fonds haben das ist normal
ich möchte hier keine Abfrage machen
aber ich würde die Wette eingehen dass
unter denjenigen die hier sitzen viele
dabei sind die auch ein ETF haben oder
ein Vorhaben ja und da bin ich ganz fest
von überzeugt und ich bin weiß es auch
persönlich und ich bin aber auch von
manchen in der Regierung aber ich bin
auch ganz fest davon überzeugt dass von
den referatsleitungen von den
Abteilungsleitungen und von den anderen
Staatssekretären die in verschiedenen
Ministerien arbeiten auch viele Menschen
fondszeiten oder ETFs und es gibt aus
guten Grund so wie wir das ja eben
gesagt haben keinen Grund weshalb man es
offenlegen muss und wenn sie dann sagen
ja profitiert man davon ja sag mal so es
gibt zwei Möglichkeiten davon zu
profitieren die eine Möglichkeit ist
dass wir gute Politik machen ja dass wir
es vielleicht schaffen irgendwo dafür zu
sorgen dass wir eine gute viel Strategie
haben das ist den Unternehmen dass die
eine dass die gute
Wettbewerbsbedingungen haben ja dass die
Unternehmen gut gedeihen und das ist das
ist den Unternehmen gut geht das schafft
gute Arbeitsplätze und dass erneut den
Wohlstand in Deutschland daraus zu
konstruieren dass ich das mache damit
mein Aktien der die Aktienkurse steigen
das tut mir leid das finde ich weit
hergeholt und dann gibt es eine andere
theoretische Möglichkeit das ist
Förderbescheide gibt dass das dort
irgendwo das eine Unternehmen in einem
vorderen drin ist was irgendwo eine
Einzelförderung bekommt da hat der
Minister ja schon das Beispiel mit der
Lufthansa genannt ich nenne ihn ein
anderes Beispiel wenn wenn sie irgendwo
ein DAX ETF haben ja das ist das
klassischste was man sozusagen hat wenn
man einen DAX ETF hat dann und sie jetzt
hier irgendwo im Haushaltsausschuss
sitzen würden dann würden sie mit
entscheiden darüber ob Siemens z.B wenn
es ein großes Geschäft in Afrika macht
und eine hermesbürgschaft bekommt weil
große Hermes Eigenschaften nämlich im
Haushaltsausschuss entschieden werden
und haben Sie sich jemals gefragt wenn
sie so eine hermesbürgschaft sozusagen
darüber entschieden haben ob sie eine
Siemens Aktie in ihrem DAX ETF haben
natürlich haben sie das nicht weil es
völlig normal ist ja und und und weil
wir das deswegen nicht offen legen
müssen und deswegen kann ich nur sagen
natürlich ich habe das eben transparent
gemacht ich bin in
Fonds investiert und ich habe ein
vermögensverwaltungsmandat mit der Bank
und darüber habe ich ein ganz breit
gestreutes Portfolio sowie alle Menschen
die Infos investiert sind und ich muss
sie nicht erklären dass wenn Sie einem
Freund investiert sind ein Form
mindestens ein paar dutzende Unternehmen
hat und wenn sie in breit gestreut wie
das viele verbraucherschützer empfehlen
eben auch einen was weiß ich was ein ETF
über den MSI MSCI World haben sind viele
tausend Unternehmen investiert und äh
wie ich ihm sagte niemand interessiertes
welche Unternehmen in den Fonds sind
vielen Dank
herzlichen Dank Herr Philipp nicht dass
bei ihnen noch irgendwie Nachfragen
kommen nach Empfehlungen welche sie das
nicht wieso geben können aber die Gefahr
besteht ja vielleicht nicht ich finde es
auch spannend wer wer irgendwie ein
Aktien investiert hat das würde mir auch
interessieren aber das kriegen wir heute
nicht raus wir haben der Kollege ernst
hat das vorhin erwähnt wir sollten
angesichts der Kürze der Fragezeichen
schon Wert darauf legen dass die
Antworten umfänglich sind ich habe bei
der Kollegin Klöckner ein etwas
unzufriedenes Gesicht will jetzt nicht
sagen aber zufriedene Verhalten gesehen
ich weiß nicht ob alle beantwortet sind
sie sind nicht beantworten deshalb wäre
es in der Tat gut gewesen
gerne da und will auch darauf eingehen
ich habe nie die Frage gestellt ob der
Minister gewusst hätte dass sie vorhin
der Wirtschaft waren das ist etwas
zynisch das so zu unterstellen wenn er
das nicht gewusst hätte wäre es wirklich
schwierig ich habe eine andere Frage
gestellt nein die wurde nicht er hat
eine Frage beantwortet mir unterstellt
die ich nicht gestellt habe ich bin
gerade dabei man sich doch ganz locker
wenn sie und das ist der Punkt hätten
wir vorher das den Frage Modus gelassen
dann wäre das gegangen und meine Frage
ist gewesen wusste der Minister
ja da liegen die Nerven gleich darf ich
mal ganz kurz wusste der Minister meine
Frage ist gewesen ob der Minister von
den einzelbeteiligungen wusste und wenn
ja wann und in welcher Form das war
meine Frage die ich vorhin gestellt hat
und die zweite ist gewesen die nicht
beantwortet worden ist
nachdem sie ihre Beteiligung gegenüber
dem bmwk angegeben hatten ist genau was
passiert das würde ich gerne wissen weil
es ja um das Thema Compliance und
Regelung geht hat es eine schriftliche
Reaktion des bmwk auf diese Anzeige
gegeben haben sie eine bekommen wenn ja
in welchem Inhalt
wenn ja mit welchem Inhalt und können
wir diese schriftliche Reaktion dann
bekommen oder ist eine ifg-anfrage
notwendig so vielen Dank vielleicht kann
man die noch ergänzen Herr Philipp und
dann vielleicht darf ich noch einmal
wiederholt darauf hinweisen
sie waren ja selber Ministerin dass noch
einmal von allen erwartet werden muss
dass sie sich an Recht und Gesetz halten
die Rechtsnorm habe ich jetzt mehrfach
ausgeführt und ich natürlich wusste weil
Udo Philipp als ehemaliger Unternehmer
und Wirtschaftsmanager
in Wirtschaft investiert hat dass er
Unternehmensbeteiligung hatte als mir
mitgeteilt wurde dass die Compliance
Pakete ausgeteilt wurden und alles okay
ist weil die Sache für mich erledigt und
ich komme wieder zu dem Punkt der
ja insgesamt politisch verhandelt wird
um einmal von der Landwirtschaft zu
reden wenn wir über düngevorschriften
oder über Bewirtschaftungsformen reden
profitieren landwirtschaftliche
Unternehmen Bayer beispielsweise BASF
vielleicht wenn man sich für
Pestizideinsatz einsetzt
wenn wir wissen wollen ob
Abteilungsleiter Ministerin
Staatssekretäre Landwirtschaftsausschuss
Mitglieder Fonds haben in den Bayer und
BASF Aktien drin sind dann finde ich
kann man diese Frage diskutieren dann
aber für alle das gleiche gilt für
Mitglieder des Verteidigungsausschusses
oder für Mitglieder im
Verteidigungsministerium ich will gar
nicht jetzt irgendwelche sie wissen dass
ich meine das geht im Grunde für alle
für mich ist wichtig dass gleiche Regeln
für alle gelten das ist überprüft worden
und das wegen der Sensibilität in
bestimmten Bereichen anderen Häusern
auch natürlich da ist geprüft wird ob
die compliancevorschriften eingehalten
sind und das ist passiert
so vielen Dank Beteiligung ist was
anderes als eine öffentliche Aktie
vielen dank vielen Dank jetzt kann Herr
Philipp noch meine Frage war beantworten
habe kommen wir zur zweiten Frage Runde
bitte schön sie haben das Wort wenn ich
nicht präzise genug geantwortet habe
Frau Klöckner tut mir das leid ich hatte
ihn ja eben gesagt dass dass ich eine
Woche ungefähr eine Woche ich habe die
Tage jetzt nicht gezählt bevor ich ähm
die berufen wurde die Abteilung Z die
Zentralabteilung wo auch die Compliance
Abteilung drin ist gefragt habe ob es
ein Problem gibt damit dass ich direkt
Unternehmensbeteiligung habe und so
weiter so wie ich das eben gesagt habe
und darauf habe ich eine Reaktion
bekommen diese Reaktion war schriftlich
das ist korrekt so
ich möchte mal als amtschefin sagen dass
wegen personendatenschutz wenn Herr
Philipp das offengelegt hat mehr
offengelegt hat
als er im Zweifel musste und dann eben
gesagt wurde dass diese
das damit die Regeln auch klar sind dann
würde ich das gerne noch mal überprüfen
er hat es offen gelegt und er hat eine
Antwort bekommen und was wir an Sie
rausgeben würde ich dann unter Personen
Datenschutzgründen ich hoffe das ist
alles auch in Ihrem Interesse das könnte
man ja auch von Abgeordneten verlangen
oder von anderen da wissen wir ja wie
das geht alles gut es ist so gerne dann
dann freue ich mich drauf halten wir
fest dass ich das dann schriftlich
bekomme mir geht's gar nicht um Personen
Daten sondern die ist das schriftliche
okay würde ich gerne sehen okay gut
damit kommen wir zur zweiten Runde die
gehen jetzt an die Mitglieder des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
und die erste Frage stellt bitte Frau
Scheer von der SPD
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender meine
Frage geht an Herrn Habeck und zwar Herr
Minister ich wollte noch mal auf einen
ganz anderen Themenkomplexe sprechen
kommen die Frage der Besetzung von
ExpertInnen und besetzen ExpertInnen für
Gremien für Expertenkommission Daten sie
ja in ihrem Statement um 17.5 darauf
hingewiesen dass da ein Graubereich
existiere der aufgefallen sei bei der
normalen Prüfung und wie kann man es
ihrer Meinung nach vermeiden dass solche
Graubereiche künftig im Vorfeld
identifizierbar sind also sprich wie ist
speziell bei der Besetzung bei der
Auswahl von künftigen Expertinnen und
Experten in Anwendung der Compliance
Regeln zu gewährleisten dass solche
Graubereiche nicht existieren und eben
entsprechende interessens
verquickungsanscheine auch vermieden
werden können vielen Dank
danke die nächste Frage geht an Herrn
Jung bitte ja
Vorsitzender ich habe zunächst eine
Bemerkung und sie ist klar dass Regeln
für alle gelten egal in welchen Häusern
sie Staatssekretär sind das aber
natürlich in dem Fall in dem ein
Staatssekretär im Wirtschaftsministerium
für Unternehmen für Start-ups zuständig
ist sich eine besondere Sensibilität
ergibt ist offenkundig und hat sich ja
in diesem Fall auch dadurch realisiert
dass ein Unternehmen in dem sie eine
Beteiligung haben eine Förderung
bekommen hat das ist der Grund warum
nachgefragt wird und ich möchte jetzt
noch mal fragen ich habe sie jetzt so
verstanden sie sind beteiligt an einem
Unternehmen ist eine Förderung von
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium bekommen
indem sie Staatssekretär sind aber sie
haben weder mit dem Unternehmen über
diesen Förderantrag gesprochen noch mit
irgendjemand in dem Haus darüber
gesprochen sie haben gar niemandem
darüber gesprochen hatten also auch
keine Kenntnis davon heute haben sie
aber Kenntnis davon haben sie das erst
durch ihre Recherchen dann erfahren wann
haben sie dadurch davon Kenntnis
erhalten
erste Frage zweite Frage betrifft die
formbeteiligung da möchte ich fragen
haben sie es offengelegt dass sie den
Form Manager mit dem geschäftlich
verbunden sind wusste dass der Minister
hätten sie ist auch für eine gute Idee
gehalten wenn Sie das gewusst hätten
dass jemand mit dem der Staatssekretär
geschäftlich verbunden wird sie in einem
Beirat berät und er in ausdrücklich
empfiehlt danke hier jung die nächste
Frage geht
ja herzlichen Dank dafür mit der gehört
dass nicht nur maßig vorbildlich
verhalten hat sondern auch Herr Philipp
sie Compliance Regeln sogar
übererfüllter den man die
formbeteiligung angegeben hat in der Tat
würde ich gerne den Vorschlag aufgreifen
dass bevor hier mit Schmutz geworfen
wird den es vielleicht gar nicht gibt
wird auch überlegen ob wir nicht erst
mal gleich ziehen ja und auch das für
uns hier in diesen beiden Ausschüssen
sagen dass wir das angeben werden Fonds
beteiligt ist ich möchte aber gerne noch
mal nachhaken bei den Compliance Regeln
welche weiteren Compliance Regeln gibt
es denn außer die Frage ob man den Fonds
investiert ist jemand auf mich ja gar
nicht angeben muss die jetzt wichtig
sind für diesen Fall hat Udo Philipp
alle diese Regeln erfüllt ja und dann
würde ich noch einmal sie hat gesagt sie
sind mehr in Fonds investiert als in
Einzelaktien habe ich das jetzt richtig
verstanden dass sie in diesen vier
kleinen Unternehmen einzunehmen und
investiert sind und ansonsten in Fonds
und war das auch eine konkrete
Compliance Entscheidung und warum ist
das besser für die Compliance danke
gerichtet das war mir jetzt nicht ganz
klar
wegen mir kann es die Regierung gerne
selbst entscheiden wer die Frage
beantwortet oder soll ich jemand
benennen noch Thema
hilfreicherweise einfach dann geht die
Frage an Herrn Philipp
an Herrn Philipp okay
alle Regeln ein bisschen doof anderen
habe ich es waren mehrere Fragen sich so
einfach aus einem zuordnen okay so die
nächste Frage stellt Frau bitte
ja vielen Dank ich habe zunächst Fragen
an Herrn Habig mit Blick auf Jochen
Wermut Jochen Wermut ist ich sitze hier
auf ungefähr 12 Uhr
Großspender ihrer Partei seit 2016 über
eine Millionen Euro gespendet und ihr
Staatssekretär ist Kommanditist gewesen
in einem der Gesellschaften von
dem Großspender
ist ein Gesellschafter der am Kapital
einer Gesellschaft beteiligt ist denn
ich persönlich haftet aber mit der
Einlage Stichwort Insolvenz
können Sie ausschließen dass es Projekte
des Herrn Wermut gibt die vom
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium finanziell
gefördert werden und wenn sie das nicht
ausschließen können und wissen in welche
Förderung erhält Herr Wermut und Frage
stehen sie selbst mit ihm in Verbindung
oder standen sie mit ihm in Verbindung
mit Herrn Wermut oder mit seinen Fonds
oder mit seinem Geschäftspartner
Glas Hemke oder mit dessen
klimabewährung German Zero und dann habe
ich Fragen zum Thema
leider so beschlossen ich jetzt auch
gerne anders gehabt so die nächste Frage
ist ja in der geht an Herrn unterwegs
ja vielen Dank erstmal Mitglieder des
Deutschen Bundestages sind verpflichtet
ihre Beteiligung mit mandatsantritt
offenzulegen oder auch ihre
Nebeneinkünfte transparent anzuzeigen
letzte Woche haben sie ihr Minister
Habeck
eigentlich gesagt das bmwk hätte so
ziemlich die die weitreichendsten
Compliance Regeln und da stelle ich mir
die Frage warum diese Pflichten bei
hohen Beamten dann nicht gleich mit
reingekommen sind also mit geregelt
worden sind und deswegen würde ich sie
gerne fragen was jetzt ihre
Schlussfolgerung aus dieser Debatte ist
danke in der Weg die letzte Frage geht
an Herrn lenkert vielen Dank Herr
Vorsitzender in einem Artikel des
Spiegel vom 20 August 2022 wird Egbert
legel damals Generalbevollmächtigter
gastprom Germany GmbH heute
Geschäftsführer der Security energy for
Europe GmbH Interview und ich zitiere
aus dem Artikel Spiegel wer rief an läge
das Wirtschaftsministerium ob ich mit
diesen Posten vorstellen könnte die Rede
war von einer Aufgabe nationalen
Interesse vier Stunden später hatte ich
das erste Datenpaket mit den wichtigsten
Unterlagen auf den Computer und eine
Einladung zur fix zum Traffics mit der
Bundesnetzagentur für die nächsten
Morgen 8 Uhr Herr Minister ich frage Sie
wer hat Herrn lege angesprochen gab es
ein offizielles Auswahlverfahren für den
Post des Generalbevollmächtigten der
Gast vom Germany GmbH und
wenn ja wer kannte aus dem bmwk Herrn
lege und in welchen privaten oder
geschäftlichen Verhältnis standen die
Person im Vorfeld zueinander
willkommen zu den Antworten Herr
Minister vielen Dank ich beginne mit der
Frage von Frau Schär die ja abgesetzt
ist ein bisschen von dem anderen Frage
komplett
die Vorschriften für Compliance sind ja
sagen immer interpretierbar und um sie
klarer zu interpretieren ist es meine
Ansicht nach ein gutes und Privates
Mittel wie ist jetzt bei der
Neubesetzung der Diener Geschäftsführer
auch angewandt wird aktiv die
Auswahl Mitglieder zu fragen also nicht
zu sagen wir gehen mal davon aus dass
ihr keine Trauzeugen beruft oder ein
Beispiel zu nennen sondern zu sagen seid
ihr mit denen so und so viel Bewerbern
verwandt verschwiegert irgendwie in
irgendeiner Beziehung stehen die die
Compliance
Vorgaben verletzen oder berühren das
wird uns am Ende uns allen immer noch
keine absolute Sicherheit geben aber
dann muss man sozusagen ja schriftlich
die Unwahrheit sagen oder sich wirklich
sehr schlechte erinnern können also aus
der Unterstellung die ja quasi die
Dienst Norm ist dass alle selbst
verantwortlich darüber wachen ein
aktives Handeln zu machen das scheint
mir ein sinnvolles Vorgehen zu sein und
jetzt ob es erstmalig ist weiß ich nicht
genau aber um es jetzt wird es bei der
Diener so auch angewandt und es so
angewandt t worden
dann zu den anderen Fragen die
mindestens teilweise mehr gestellt
worden ich möchte auf Africa green Tag
kurz eingehen es gab ja eine Förderung
in dieser Legislatur oder philipp hat es
gerade erwähnt diese Förderung ist aus
der Abteilung 2 das ist die
Energieeffizienz und
klimaschutzabteilung heraus gemacht
worden das heißt also der
Abteilungsleiter und da steht nicht der
dem Organigramm nach dem Staatssekretär
sondern in diesem Fall wäre es Patrick
reichen gewesen aber wie Udo Philipp
ausgeführt hat ging es gar nicht im
Dienstweg hoch also insofern ist das
meine Ansicht nach auszuschließen das
Uwe Philipp davon wusste oder profitiert
war was Herrn Böhme angeht
wie gesagt ich habe Wert darauf gelegt
dass eben nicht nur große professionelle
mit uns allen irgendwie uns allen
irgendwie bekannte Startup Unternehmer
und Unternehmer da reingehen sondern wir
da das studentische Milieu begreifen
noch einmal das ist ja das ist ja das
Besondere daran damals als es gegründet
wurde waren ist Studenten es ist jetzt
also nicht
hat noch nicht die Power von Elon Musk
Möglichkeiten sondern fünf studentische
fünf Studierende Gründen ein Startup
Unternehmen für das Studierende die
inzwischen keine Studierenden mehr sind
das ist eine finanzielle Beteiligung
dort gab das wusste ich nicht es ist
aber auch relevant an dieser Stelle und
zwar aus doppelten Gründen erstens die
Form Beteiligung
in diesem Fall ist es ja ein Unternehmen
nämlich zurück dann ist es nur aus einem
Grund der relevant weil der Beirat nicht
in einer
Position ist wo seine Beratung dazu
führen kann dass die politischen
Entscheidungen dem Unternehmen in einem
direkten Sinne also der der der der
Nährung von privaten Interesse zu Gute
führt noch einmal 29 Unternehmen derzeit
in einem breiten Stakeholder Prozess das
ist also im Grunde neutralisiert und der
Wert dieses
Mitglied des Beirats ist da drin dass er
eine soweit wir wissen einmalige
Expertise hatten mich aus der Uni für
Studierende
die Frage von Frau Nestle die Compliance
Regeln sind nicht nur eingehalten worden
sondern übererfüllt würden oder philipp
hat mehr Transparenz geschaffen als
viele andere Mitglieder von Regierungen
und weil Herr von wegen von der Weg das
angesprochen hat soweit ich das weiß
müssen Bundestagsabgeordnete ihre
Beteiligung erst ab 5% offenlegen wenn
das richtig ist
und Fonds auch nicht angeben
insofern sind hier ich weiß gar nicht ob
deine Beteiligung unter oder über 5%
sind aber sozusagen mehr geschaffen
worden er müsste es gar nicht machen hat
es getan und die die die Vorschriften
für die Bundestagsabgeordneten sind eben
nicht so dass man vorm Beteiligung oder
Fonds überhaupt aufdecken muss ich habe
schon darauf hingewiesen dass das ja es
sind ja berechtigte Fragen das finde ich
richtig dass man diese Fragen stellt
aber sie müssten dann eben in der
politischen Logik für alle geltenden
Beispiele wie hermesbürgerschaften
beispielsweise genannt
innerhalb der Bundesregierung gibt es
ein Ministerium das schärfere Regeln
sich gegeben hat das ist das
Bundesfinanzministerium das im Frühjahr
21 in der Folge des Wirecard Skandals
eine schärfere
einchecken und Leitfaden für seine
Mitarbeiter herausgegeben hat dort gibt
es quasi
Kategorien die schärferen Transparenz
oder teilweise auch
handelsverbotsvorschriften unterliegen
sie erinnern sich in den Bayer Card
Skandal das wusste ich alles nicht das
haben wir jetzt aufgearbeitet und nach
Aktenlage in meinem Haus damals ja von
Peter Altmaier geführt und ich muss
unterstellen das war bei den anderen
Häusern ebenfalls wurde bewusst
entschieden diese schärferen komplett
nicht zu implementieren in den anderen
Häusern
und würden sie im Blick imitiert worden
sein würde Udo Philips
Investitionen selbst danach völlig
rechtmäßig sein er würde sozusagen auch
den schärfsten Vorschriften unterliegen
warum in dem Wirtschaftsministerium in
dem
Landwirtschaftsministerium in dem
Gesundheitsministerium und so weiter
diese Regeln damals nicht implementiert
wurden das weiß ich nicht genau aber
noch einmal diese Debatte halte ich für
sinnvoll die kann gerne geführt werden
ich habe schon gesagt europäisches
Kranken Parlament Europäische Kommission
Frankreich mit auch den
Eigentumsverhältnissen und den
Schuldverhältnissen das kann man gerne
alles diskutieren das schaue ich
überhaupt nicht dann aber für alle für
alle Häuser
gegebenenfalls für Exekutive wie
Legislative entlang der Frage ist es
transparent genug haben wir genug gegen
Lobby Einfluss getan die Regeln sind
nicht nur eingehalten worden die sind
überfüllt worden Regeln Verschärfung
frage ich den parlamentarischen Raum am
Ende geben Sie die Gesetze das können
wir gerne diskutieren da hat das bmwk
überhaupt nichts dagegen weder Philipp
noch echt eine Person hat
Herr Philipp bitte ja gerne also dann
fange ich mit der Frage von einem Jungen
an ich habe in der Tat nicht mit dem
Unternehmen gesprochen der ich hatte
eine Vereinbarung mit dem Gründer von
Afrika die greentec getroffen als sich
nach Schleswig-Holstein gegangen bin
Anfang 2019 dass dass wir nicht mehr in
diesen Dingen miteinander sprechen
sollten und das heißt er hat mich nicht
kontaktiert mit irgendwelchen
fördergeschichten wie auch immer oder
irgendwelchen anderen Dingen wo ich im
geschäftlichen rate gegeben können ich
hatte ja mal gesagt ich war als Business
Angel tätig ich habe diese Dinge wo ich
irgendwelchen Unternehmen mit Rat und
Tat beiseite gestanden habe alle
niedergelegt als ich in
Schleswig-Holstein
Staatssekretär wurde das heißt ganz
konkret ich hatte wirklich keine
Kenntnis keine Kenntnis dass das
Unternehmen ein Antrag gestellt hat ich
hatte keine Kenntnis dass das ist Werder
und wieder irgendwo in einen Antrag
genehmigt wurde wir haben
das recherchiert und haben das ich weiß
nicht wann ich die Kenntnis bekommen
habe aber jedenfalls vor wenigen Tagen
ist das ist das bei mir jetzt angekommen
aber erst nachdem wir aufwändig
recherchiert haben dann die Frage zu den
zu
der vorteilung ist ja schon schon
beantwortet kommt dann zu also zu zur
bei first Momentum Ventures dann komme
ich zu der Frage von Frau Nestle die war
nicht beantwortet zwar die Frage haben
sie den Herrn Böhmer vorgeschlagen die
das habe ich in meinem ersten Antwort
beantwortet ich habe die
Staatssekretärin gefragt denkt daran
dass wir aus studentischen Umfeld was
bekommen und Udo Philipp wusste davon
dass es das gibt und hat mehreren Namen
genannt insofern ja aber in einem
Prozess wohnamen gesammelt worden aber
sie haben ihn vorgeschlagen sie uns
nicht offengelegt dass Sie geschäftlich
verbunden sind und sie glauben das ist
kein Compliance Fall ist ich haben will
wir haben das ja jetzt überprüft ob es
ein Compliance Fall ist
und ich habe noch einmal gesagt die
Frage die zu beantworten wäre profitiert
das Unternehmen von der Mitgliedschaft
in den Beirat
das ist aber meine Antwort
dann komme ich zu der Frage von Nestle
Entschuldigung also die dann kommen
komme ich zu der Frage von Frau Nest von
Frau Nestle Fonds versus Einzelaktien vs
der der vier einzelbeteiligungen die die
ich hatte das vor ja mehrfach gesagt die
es ist sehr wichtig wenn man Compliance
Regeln einzuhalten hat dass man nicht
gegen Insiderregeln verstößt das macht
man indem man entweder sich an Fonds
beteiligt oder wenn man an Aktien
beteiligt ist dass man die über ein
vermögensverwaltungsmandat zum Beispiel
bei einer Bank macht ich mache das
genauso das heißt Aktien sind sind beim
über ein vermögensverwaltungsmandat und
und die Chance sind Sinn bei beiden ist
es immer dasselbe es ist ein eine
externe Person oder Institution die
darüber entscheidet welche Aktien
gekauft werden wann sie gekauft werden
wann sie wieder verkauft werden und so
weiter und so fort
dann komme ich zu Frau von Storch die
ist es in der Tat so dass dass ich ähm
Kommanditist bei einem Fonds von Herrn
Wermut war das lange her die dir wenn
man Kommanditist in irgendwo ist dann
ist das bei einem geschlossenen Fonds
kann man in ein geschlossenen Form
investiert man immer über ein
Kommanditanteil das ist total üblich das
ist bei Private Equity Fonds so und das
ist auch bei bei
Immobilienfonds so oder wo auch immer ja
das ist das ist halt die Art und Weise
wie man dort investiert ich bin dort
ausgeschieden fast ein Jahr bevor ich
ins Ministerium also ins bmwk kam also
das ist sie können mich natürlich jetzt
ich weiß ich theoretisch Fragen mit wem
ich in meinen 30 Jahren Berufsleben
überall schon mal Geschäfte gemacht habe
nein das ist das ist die das ist die
wenn Sie es ganz präzise machen wollen
ist die kann ich Ihnen gleich noch mal
ganz präzise die die Daten geben ich bin
nicht im November 22 ausgeschieden das
ist eine fehl im Information also wenn
sie es weiß nicht ob ersetzt wenn sie es
wollen mache ich jetzt ich war die die
ich bin 11 Monate vor meinem
Dienstantritt wirksam ausgeschieden ich
habe dem vormanagement im Juli 2019
schriftlich mitgeteilt dass ich gerne
ausschalten möchte da waren mehrere die
da die dort raus wollten die wir haben
dann gemeinsam dort mit mit verhandelt
und der verkaufsvater der Vertrag dass
ich ausscheide oder am 27 November 2020
unterzeichnet die die
das ist zu der Frage von von Herrn
Wermut wie gesagt also wenn sie jetzt
recherchieren mit dem ich irgendwann in
der Vergangenheit mal Geschäfte gemacht
habe oder wo ich irgendwann mal noch vor
investiert war was ich für eine Aktie
vor 30 Jahren gehalten habe ich glaube
es ist irrelevant die die
ja ich glaube die ja die Frage nach den
MdB ist ob die mehr offene legen als wir
die ist ja beantwortet worden dann die
Frage zu Herrn läge die die Herr lege
ist in der Tat so den habe ich
angesprochen aber den kannte ich vorher
nicht wieso habe ich denn dann
angesprochen weil ich weil ich halt mich
umgehört habe bei bei verschiedensten
Experten in der Industrie wir brauchten
jemanden der sofort zur Verfügung steht
ich glaube sie erinnern sich
wahrscheinlich wie das wie das damals
war wir haben das Unternehmen letztlich
in einer Nacht und Nebelaktion
übernehmen müssen dort gab es einen
russischen Geschäftsführer der russische
Geschäftsführer war sehr eng mit mit der
russischen Regierung verwandelt wir
mussten ja von einer Sekunde auf die
andere wirklich von einer Sekunde auf
die andere eine Person haben die in der
Lage war dieses Geschäft zu verstehen
und die in der Lage war auch sofort
anzufangen und das heißt ich mich dann
eben umgehört sowohl bei Menschen aus
der Industrie die ich gut kenne weil bei
anderen Experten die ich gut kenne ob
sie irgendjemand kennen und dann gab es
dort eine Liste von Menschen und
tatsächlich war eine Person dabei die
von mehreren gleichzeitig empfohlen
wurde und dass es immer läge und erlege
ist sehr kompetent da da können sie sich
wenn sie immer kennenlernen sicherlich
auch von von von überzeugen jedenfalls
ich kannte ihn vorher nicht dazu möchte
ich noch einen Satz sagen und an der
Stelle würde ich einmal sagen dass ich
diese Befragung umdreht wie gut dass wir
jemanden hatten der in der Wirtschaft
suchen konnte dass sie ein
Geschäftsführer finden weil das nämlich
Gazprom war Gazprom Germania die
übernommen werden mussten und hätten wir
das nicht irgendwie irgendwelche auf die
auf die Kette gekriegt hätten wir eine
ganz andere Diskussion heute also da hat
sich ausgezahlt dass jemand Kenntnisse
hat und
jemanden finden kann und die Situation
ist ja bekannt wie sie ausgelöst wurde
lieber Ernst sie wissen ja ganz genau
weil sie mich gerade so angucken bevor
ich weiter Rede was das Problem war
nämlich die Verbundenheit mit Russland
freut mich dass sie das Ansprechen
spielt jetzt hier nur keine Rolle jetzt
merke ich nur dass die Fraktion DIE
LINKE in den Eindruck ist erledigt okay
aber meine Fragen sind noch nicht
beantwortet in Bezug aufhängen Wermut
und seine Projekte ich hatte gefragt ob
sie ausschließen können dass das
Wirtschaftsministerium in Projekte
investiert hat die Herr wer oder
gefördert hat in die Herr Wermut
investiert ist und ich hatte gefragt in
welchem Verhältnis stehen sie zu einem
Wermut kennen sie ihnen treffen sie ihn
ähm sind sie mit seinen Investmentfonds
ansonsten in Verbindung mit seinem
Geschäftspartner Klaus Hemke oder mit
seiner dessen Klimabewegung German Zero
sagen sie mich sie ich kenne Herrn
Wermut aus zwei oder drei Begegnung
ist Parteimitglied von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen wenn ich das richtig weiß
jedenfalls ist ja auf den Parteitagen
und in dem Zusammenhang redet man
miteinander ansonsten weiß ich nicht wo
die Relevanz der Frage ist ich kann die
nicht beantworten so wie ich sie zu
vielen Unternehmen nicht beantworten
könnte und ich sehe auch nicht was es
zur Sache tut das werden sie dann noch
sehen das stelle ich trotzdem die Frage
German zero
glashemke
in Verbindung mit denen stehen ob sie
die kennen und Klaas Hemke ob sie mit
dem in einer Verbindung stehen oder ihn
können der Name gesagt mir nichts wenn
er mit Jürgen Wermut irgendwann mal
durch die Gegend gelaufen ist vielleicht
habe ich mal gesehen ich habe aber kein
Gesicht zu dem Namen und auch die
Stiftung meine ich ist vor zwei oder
drei Jahren mal gegründet worden aber
ich stehen keiner Verbindung zu mir
okay damit sind wir mit dieser Frage
Runde durch und ich gebe zurück an die
Kollegen vielen Dank
wenn wir über die Transparenz von
Abgeordneten reden und um Ministerium
müssen wir ja weil wir so ein hohes
Interesse der Öffentlichkeit hat man
auch mal über Transparenz bei
Journalisten nachdenken aber das wird
man ja sowieso noch irgendwie mal Regeln
deshalb ein anderes Thema als heute
Abend oder heute Vormittag reden wir
jetzt in der dritten Runde über die
nächsten Fragen insbesondere Frau
Kollegin Werner beginnt
ja vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender ich
würde an der Stelle immer noch mal ganz
kurz betonen wollen dass es sehr gut und
auch wichtig ist dass wir eine
start-up-strategie haben und eben auch
der Bundesregierung dafür noch mal
danken meine Fragen richten sich an
Herrn Staatssekretär Philipp sie haben
gesagt dass sie als Staatssekretär keine
konkreten Entscheidungen zu Förderung
treffen wenn aber Förderrichtlinien
erstellt werden werden dann nicht
bereits Entscheidungen getroffen die
mögliche Investitionen in bestimmte
Bereiche absehbar machen und die zweite
Frage gab es während ihrer bisherigen
Amtszeit als Staatssekretär eine aktive
Einflussnahme auf Unternehmen an denen
sie Anteile besitzen danke schön
klar in der Zeit das Wort hat Julia
Klöckner Dankeschön meine Frage oder
Fragen gehen wieder ausschließlich an
den Staatssekretären erstens sie haben
mit Pressemitteilungen vom 18 mai diesen
jahresauskünfte über ihre Beteiligungen
gegeben und in dieser Pressemitteilung
werden einzelne Unternehmensbeteiligung
das ist unter zwei ausführlich
dargestellt auffällig ist es andere
Beteiligung das ist unter vier da nicht
weitere Details ausgeführt werden warum
gibt es hier unterschiedliche
Transparenz über die ja heute den ganzen
Tag gesprochen wird und können Sie eine
gleiche Transparenz wie auch bei zwei
also unter Punkt 4 ermöglichen zweite
Frage können Sie ausschließen wirklich
ausschließen das weitere Beteiligungen
und Investitionen Beteiligung und
Investition von ihnen von den Förderung
des bmwk profitiert haben drittens
dritte Frage haben sie die
leitungsvorlage zur Benennung der
Mitglieder in den Beirat junge digitale
Wirtschaft haben sie die gezeichnet wenn
Sie die gezeichnet haben warum haben sie
diese Vorlage gezeichnet und nicht auf
einen Interessenkonflikt hingewiesen und
vielleicht um noch mal zu einem anderen
Thema zu kommen warum waren sie
eigentlich nicht in der
Findungskommission für die Nachfolge der
dehnergeschäftsführung ist ja obwohl die
Beteiligung der Dehner in ihrem
Zuständigkeitsbereich liegt aber sie
haben dann die leitungsvorlage der
Auswahl Entscheidung von Herrn Schäfer
gekennzeichnet und das muss es jetzt
gewesen sein
Frau Kollegin Netzer bitte
ja herzlichen Dank ich möchte
zurückkommen auf einen Gedanken den Sie
Herr Minister eingangs der letzten
Ausschusssitzung geäußert hatten nämlich
der Zusammenhang zwischen dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz das die Koalition gerade
berät es ist ein wichtiges
Gesetzesvorhaben dass wir momentan da
gemeinsam Vorhaben ich möchte sie in
diesem Zusammenhang Fragen sehen Sie
eine Verknüpfung dieses
Gesetzesvorhabens mit der Personalie des
ausgeschiedenen
Staatssekretärs und gibt es aus ihrer
Sicht Auswirkungen auf dieses Gesetz
durch die neue Besetzung herzlichen Dank
danke schön lieber Herr Kollege bevor
ich sie vergessen haben Sie jetzt das
Wort
ja Herr Vorsitzender vielen Dank meine
Frage geht an Minister Robert Habeck
wann wird in Ausschüssen der Vermerk zum
Umgang mit möglichen
Interessenkonflikten für Staatssekretär
Philipp weitergeleitet
bei Herrn reichen war das ungefähr nach
zehn Tagen wir haben jetzt das bmwk
gefragt man sagt der Schriftwechsel zum
Amtsantritt zwischen Staatssekretär
Philipp und der Compliance Abteilung sei
in der Erstellung und es würde noch ein
paar Tage dauern sieben bis zehn Tage
deswegen die Frage warum liegt dieser
Vermerk nicht heute schon vor
das hätte vielleicht hier auch manches
und erspart vielen Dank
Dankeschön Kollege kommen den bitte ja
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender meine
erste Frage richtet sich an den
Staatssekretären Philips Philipp es geht
noch mal um die Berufung von Sebastian
Böhmer in den Beirat junge digitale
Wirtschaft der Minister sagte gerade sie
hätten mehrere nebenher Herrn Böhmer
vorgeschlagen ich hätte gerne gewusst
wie viele neben Herrn Böhmer wurden von
Ihnen vorgeschlagen und welches
Verhältnis hatten sie zu Herrn Böhmer
sind sie mit ihm nur geschäftlich
verwandelt über den Fond in Herr Böhmer
anbietet oder sind sie auch
freundschaftlich mit ihm verbunden und
meine zweite Frage geht an den Minister
der Minister hat das bmwk überprüft ob
der Beirat junge digitale Wirtschaft
Handlungsempfehlungen oder Expertisen
abgegeben hat die direkt oder auch
indirekt sie haben bisher immer nur über
direkte Zuständigkeiten direkte
Einflussnahme gesprochen die direkt oder
indirekt Unternehmen betreffen an denen
Fonds von Herrn Böhmer von Herrn Böhmer
beteiligt sind vielen Dank Dankeschön
Pascal Meiser für die Linke vielen Dank
Herr Vorsitzender vorweg damit die
Debatte nicht irgendwie eine falsche
Richtung geht also entscheidend bei der
Frage der Befangenheit ist doch nicht ob
ein führendes Mitglied der
Bundesregierung oder ein Staatssekretär
gleichzeitig eine aktive Rolle in einem
Unternehmen als Geschäftsführer oder
ähnliches oder einem Beirat Aufsichtsrat
einnimmt sondern ob er oder sie
wirtschaftlich finanziell davon
profitiert das ist der Punkt und dann
müssen wir sauber bleiben Ihre
Argumentationslinie verschleiert das ein
wenig
ich habe eine konkrete Frage Philipp
noch mal sie haben leider auf meinen
ersten Versuch hin nicht geantwortet sie
haben ja wieder auf die vier direkten
Unternehmensbeteiligungen verwiesen die
auch schon per Pressemitteilung
veröffentlicht wurden aber noch mal es
gibt ja konkrete Fonds und das sind ja
nicht irgendwie DAX ETFs oder so an
denen sie beteiligt sind aufgrund einer
gewissen Historie
bleiben wir mal bei first Momentum
Ventures können Sie bitte noch mal
darlegen an welchen Startups für das
Momentum Ventures beteiligt ist meiner
Kenntnis nach ist es eine überschaubare
Zahl und haben sie diese konkreten
indirekten Beteiligung gegenüber dem
bmwk offengelegt und
jedenfalls sichergestellt dass nicht in
dem Zusammenhang irgendwie
Interessenkonflikte entstehen
danke schön sobald ich das weiß wann das
jetzt nur ausschließlich Fragen an Herrn
oder
vermerkt ist okay alles gut okay
der Beirat ja genau alles klar also zu
der Frage Auswirkungen zu der Frage wo
der wann ein Vermerk erstellt wird würde
ich gerne der amtschiffen das Wort
gleich geben da habe ich keine
Erkenntnisse darüber
geflogen was soll ich reden nicht mit
mir
das Patrick reichten dass Gebäude
Energiegesetz politisch verantwortlich
hat ist ja bekannt
ist er nicht mehr Staatssekretär ein
neuer Philipp nimmermann wird kommen das
Gesetz allerdings ist ja nicht von ihm
alleine verantwortlich worden sondern in
letzter Konsequenz im Ministerium von
mir von der Expertise von vielen Leuten
im Haus und vor allem auch im
Bauministerium mit geschrieben worden es
ist dann im Kabinett beraten worden
verändert worden und geeint worden und
jetzt im Deutschen Bundestag vor so dass
ich kurz sagen kann das Ausscheiden von
Patrick reichen hat auf die weiteren
Beratung oder die mögliche
Verabschiedung natürlich keinen Einfluss
sondern es liegt ja jetzt im Element und
die Expertise ist beratend wenn
gewünscht in allen beiden Häusern die
das Gesetz geschrieben haben natürlich
da also das ist sozusagen nicht
abzuleiten aus dem Ausscheiden von
Patrick reichen dann zur Dehner müsste
der Vorsitzende etwas sagen also der
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende und zudem zu
der Frage wann der Vermerk kommt Anja
Heiduk ich kann noch sagen dass die
Frage wie wir studentische expertise in
die in den Beirat junge digitale
Wirtschaft kommen bekommen
in Gesprächen eine Rolle gespielt hat
und dann in der Recherche hat oder
Philips zwei Namen vorgeschlagen
danach gefragt hat
ich denke wir können das auch damit
verbinden weil die Kollegin Klöckner ja
danach gefragt hat weil Herr Philipp
hier sehr klar dargelegt hat dass er von
sich aus vor Amtsantritt sich erkundigt
hat was mögliche Compliance Regeln für
das ganze Thema
finanzielle
Investitionen und vorm Beteiligungen
bedeuten das hat er vorzeitig gemacht
das hat er so gemacht dass das bmwk im
schriftlich geantwortet hat dass das
alles so in Ordnung sei und ich habe ihn
zugesagt dass wir in der Weise auch
unter den Dingen die auch Personen
Datenschutz angeht das zur Verfügung
stellen und das dürfte ja auch das
Abbilden was sie gerade angedeutet haben
es gab darüber hinaus ja keine
Notwendigkeiten
besondere Regeln für Herren Philipp zu
festzulegen weil er ja dafür die nötige
Transparenz ausdrücklich gesorgt hat
aber das würde ich jetzt im Zuge der
zügigen Beantwortung an die
Ausschussmitglieder dann auch allen zur
Verfügung stellen und ob das dann sieben
Tage dauern muss weiß ich nicht
vielleicht auch nicht
Stefan Wenzel kurz zu Dehner und dann zu
der dehnerfrage Herr philipp hat für die
Beteiligungsverwaltung am Ende
gezeichnet und Herr reichen Herrn
Grenchen habe ich gebeten in die
Findungskommission in
erfindungskommission mitzuarbeiten weil
er die Abteilung
verantwortet hat die maßgeblich hier zu
den Auftraggebern der Dehner gehören und
damit die inhaltliche Expertise an
diesem Punkt mitgebracht hat
gut dann fange ich mit Herrn Werner an
sie sagte ich würde keine wie das wäre
mit den Richtlinien und den konkreten
Entscheidungen zu zu unterhalten
tut mir leid liebe Frau Werner tut mir
leid die die
ob ich konkrete Entscheidungen zu
Förderungen treffe oder nicht und wie
das mit den Richtlinien wäre möchte erst
noch mal klar sagen es gibt natürlich
schon konkrete Entscheidungen zu
Förderung die ich treffe bei sehr großen
Unternehmen das ist das ist schon klar
aber die sehr großen Unternehmen ich bin
nicht an sehr großen Unternehmen direkt
beteiligt das habe ich ja kenntlich
gemacht die wie man mit Richtlinien
irgendwie es schaffen kann spezifische
Einzelunternehmen zu fördern weiß nicht
ob das möglich ist aber jedenfalls ist
das habe ich das nicht gemacht die die
aktive Einflussnahme auf Unternehmen
kann ich Ihnen sicher sagen dass ich
keine aktive Einflussnahme auf
Unternehmen nehme an denen ich beteiligt
bin das habe ich ja vorhin auch schon
mal ausgeführt an dem Beispiel mit
Afrika GreenTech dann zu Frau Klöckner
ich habe ja die sozusagen die direkten
Unternehmensbeteiligung kenntlich
gemacht an denen ich die die sozusagen
klassische Unternehmensbeteiligung sind
würde ich mal sagen dass dass ich
Genossenschaftsanteile bei einer
Genossenschaftsbank habe oder
aktienähnliche rechte das ist nicht
genau das gleiche aber das ist das ist
sowas ähnliches bei bei der Trio das
Bank das ist eine holländische Bank die
die glaube ich ist was anderes deswegen
habe ich das auch und war unter was
anderem dargestellt und dann dann bin
ich eben noch an der gemeinnützigen GmbH
der ökum Stiftung finanzwende GmbH mit
beteiligt das ist auch was anderes weil
das was gemeinnütziges ist wo wo wo wo
sie nicht also überhaupt nicht um
Gewinne geht sondern um Förderung von
von gemeinnützigen Zwecken
dann zu der zu der Frage mit den
Beteiligungen das ob da irgendwas
irgendwie profitiert das habe ich ja
jetzt glaube ich mehrfach gesagt bei den
bei den direkten Beteiligungen ist und
war wird ausgeschlossen sein dass dass
sich davon irgendwie befasst bin und
deswegen keine ich eben deswegen kein
Interessenkonflikt habe bei
irgendwelchen indirekten Beteiligungen
die Frage kam ja dann auch später noch
mal ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wer
sie gestellt hat ich glaube es war Herr
Meiser das dass die indirekt mitteilungs
haben wir jetzt mehrfach gesagt es sind
eben viele von von von ihnen die hier
sitzen viele von den Menschen die dir
die in der Bundesregierung arbeiten
viele Beamte haben Beteiligungen an
Fonds das ist immer so dass dann eine
externe Person jemand anderes die
Entscheidung trifft das habe ich auch
mehrfach gesagt das ist ganz wichtig und
wenn dann da irgendwo ein Unternehmen in
einem Form oder in einem ETF oder wie
auch immer von einer Förderung oder
ähnlichen profitiert das ist keine Frage
des Interessenkonflikt diese Frage
stellt sich nicht weil sonst wie ich
eben sagte haben Sie sich jemals diese
Frage gestellt wenn sie zum Beispiel
demnächst hier im Deutschen Bundestag
über die Post gesetztnavelle abstimmen
müssen nur mal so als Beispiel sie wird
es wird hoffentlich demnächst im
Bundestag kommen und dann wird man
regulieren wie viel Geld die Deutsche
Post im immer im Briefgeschäft verdient
werden sie dann in ihr Depot gucken ob
sie einen deutschen ETF haben den Dax
ETF und wenn sie den haben werden sie
sich dann der Stimme enthalten ich
glaube niemand hier hat sich diese Frage
so jemals gestellt und ich glaube sie
ist auch nicht relevant und und das das
ist wenn wenn man sagt man sollte sich
die Frage
also die sich jetzt melden die machen
sich natürlich selbstverdächtig ja es
ist also wie gesagt das hat der Minister
ja auch immer wieder gesagt man kann
Regeln auch ändern aber heute sind die
Regeln im eindeutig und dort gibt es
eben keinen Interessen liegt wenn man in
Fonds beteiligt ist so und und dann die
Frage nach dem nach der leitungsvorlage
die leitungsvorlage
leitungsvorlagenministerium gehen immer
auf dem Dienstweg ich bin in dem
Dienstweg drin ich kann mich nicht
erinnern ob ich sie gezeichnet habe aber
es ist ausgesprochen wahrscheinlich dass
ich diese bezeichnet habe also das davon
gehe ich eigentlich aus dass sie
gezeichnet habe die die damit ist und
das ist kein Interessenkonflikt gab hat
der Minister gerade beantwortet ich sehe
das genauso die die
Frage von Herrn ist glaube ich
beantwortet dann die Frage von einem
die die
zu zu Herrn Böhmer noch mal die also die
ich möchte da noch mal wiederholen Herr
Böhmer ist der
einzige nach meiner Kenntnis einzige und
sicher jedenfalls der erste der ein
studentischen Venture cablefone
gegründet hat und deswegen ist der
Böhmer da drin kenne ich ein Böhmer
geschäftlich oder freundschaftlich ich
bin mit Herrn Böhmer nicht befreundet ja
ich kenne den ich bin wirklich kein
Freund von mir den kenne ich sozusagen
aus Berufe aus professionellem Umfeld
dann die ganzen indirekten Beteiligungen
das habe ich eben beantwortet und auch
die Frage nach nach dem von Herr Meiser
welche welche Startup Unternehmen in den
Fonds drin sind auch die habe ich eben
beantwortet da es ist immer so die wie
soll man sagen die die Frage dann
vielleicht sind nur noch mal deutlicher
machen es ist irrelevant welche
Unternehmen in den Fonds bitte drin sind
weil es eben die ist keinen
Interessenkonflikt gibt wie ich es eben
gesagt habe mit dem Beispiel Siemens mit
dem Beispiel die Deutsche Post mit dem
Beispiel Lufthansa Dankeschön die alles
beantwortet welche nicht eine präzise
nicht ich habe nicht danach gefragt Herr
Staatssekretär ob sie befasst sind bei
Entscheidungen die ihre Beteiligung oder
Investitionen betreffen ich habe konkret
gefragt können Sie ausschließen das
weitere Beteiligungen Investitionen von
ihnen von den Förderungen des bmwk
profitiert haben oder profitieren nicht
ob sie damit befasst sind also ich Frau
Klöckner ich kann definitiv ausschließen
dass bei den vier Unternehmen an denen
ich direkt beteiligt bin dass ich dort
Entscheidungen getroffen habe oder
Entscheidungen treffe die zugunsten des
Unternehmens gehen wo ich die Ebene
finden über eine Förderung entscheidet
das kann ich definitiv ausschließen
also
wir haben jetzt noch den Kollegen kommen
und den Kollegen Meisel beide haben die
Auffassung das noch nicht alles
beantwortet ist vielleicht ganz kurz wir
müssen noch mal Weiterkommen ja meine
Frage hat der Minister eigentlich
beantwortet ging nämlich um die Frage
wie viel Personen insgesamt Herr Philipp
für den Beirat junge digitale Wirtschaft
vorgeschlagen hat der Minister sagte
einen weiteren neben Herrn Böhmer das
hörte sich zuvor anders an als ob es
mehrere gewesen wären können Sie mir
Philipp bestätigen dass es nur ein
weiterer nebenher Böhmer war und wenn ja
wer war das denn
wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen dass
wir bei der zweiten Runde nicht mit der
Angabe die Frage sein ich beantwortet
worden noch eine zweite Frage stellen
also das wollte ich noch mal drauf
achten Herr Kollege
ja Philipp sie haben ja meine Frage
bewertet aber sie haben sie nicht
beantwortet nämlich
welche Start-ups sich konkret hinter
first momenteventures
verstecken also wir an wie vielen first
momenteventures eigentlich beteiligt
sind welche sind das dann überlassen Sie
es da noch vielleicht der Öffentlichkeit
zu bewerten ob da möglichkeitenweise
eine Befangenheit vorliegt oder nicht
aber dafür müssen wir es ja wissen
ich würde gerne noch einmal zu dem
Besetzungsprozess des Beirats junge
digitale Wirtschaft einleiten dass sie
einen Verständnis haben was das für ein
Beirat ist und wie er sich
zusammensetzen nämlich nicht sehr
systematisch und das war davor schon
immer so erst 2013 gegründet worden ich
habe schon gesagt seitdem sind das habe
ich es vergessen 83 glaube ich Personen
dadurch gegangen immer für ein Jahr oder
zwei länger werden die nicht gerufen
also auch Herr Böhmer wird dann gab es
für ein Jahr berufen das ging immer
bewusstlos also seine Amtszeit endet
dann auch schon bald wieder und der
Beirat gibt sich selbst eine Agenda
setzt die Themen die ersetzt macht dann
in den stakeholdergesprächen in den
Konferenzen die wir zu Startup machen
seine Beiträge und berät so die
Bundesregierung im weitesten Sinne das
heißt also von einer direkten Beratung
also einzelne Mitglieder kriegen
Audienzen bei staatlichen Ministern ein
Berater des Ministers da muss man schon
sehr kühl interpretieren um das so
zusammenzufassen und wir haben die
Tradition des Hauses fortgesetzt wir
haben versucht zu der Frage der Zeit wie
schaffen wir eine aktive Start-up-Szene
in Deutschland kluge
informierte kenntnisreiche Leute
zusammenzusetzen durch
kollektives Wissen zusammen tragen und
ein Aspekt dieses Wissen zusammentragen
ist die Frage meine Frage gewesen wie
kriegen wir studentische Ausgründungen
da rein und darauf gab es dann zwei
Namen die kein anderer kannte ob Udo
Philipp weitere Namen genannt hat in den
mündlichen Gesprächen die ist dann in
diesem Kreis gibt das lässt sich glaube
ich nicht nachvollziehen aber diese
beiden Namen lassen sich nachvollziehen
und die gehen beide auf der studentische
Umfeld den zweiten kenne ich gar nicht
aber ich glaube die sind beide dann auch
übernommen worden ja so ansonsten
ist da zufällig noch werden ich habe
fünf im Haus insgesamt sind ungefähr 150
Beiratsmitglieder in den verschiedenen
beitreten interessanterweise ist einer
der fünften Beirat für die Tipp
also wie so suche so so will ich sagen
bedeutsam ist das noch nicht mal
aufgefallen bis wir jetzt mal erzählt
haben wie viele Beiträge wir haben
also die auf die Frage welche konkreten
Unternehmen in den jeweiligen Fonds sind
an denen ich sozusagen beteiligt bin die
Frage kann ich Ihnen nicht Alltag
beantworten das habe ja schon gesagt das
Entscheiden externe was dort für
Unternehmen drin sind und ich erhalte
sie das ist jetzt wieder meine Bewertung
nicht für relevant ich sehe nicht warum
man das tun muss es gibt keine Regel
dass man dass man irgendwo die Fonds
oder die Unternehmen die in Fonds drin
sind
bekannt machen muss wir haben lange
begründet warum das kein
Interessenkonflikt darstellt dann zu der
Frage von einem Comic wie viele habe ich
da vorgeschlagen ich werde der dieser
vorschlagungsprozess das waren
Brainstorming wo wir zu mehr
zusammengesetzten haben ich weiß nicht
mehr genau wie viele da mal sozusagen im
Brainstorming von mir kam aber
jedenfalls ist es so wieder Minister
gesagt hat am Schluss waren es zwei und
und damit ist hoffentlich gut weil die
ich glaube nicht dass man sozusagen da
jetzt auch noch sagen muss wenn die
anderen Person war ich kriege jedes sind
sieben Beiräte die wir haben ich habe
fünf gesagt das nicht das ist falsch im
Protokoll steht oder mir vorgehalten
wird
nee so was machen wir nicht so dann
kommt in der nächsten Runde der Kollege
Hüpfer zur Frage dann Vorsitzenden Frau
Klöckner sie genießen dass er richtig
sowas mal von der anderen Seite zu sehen
ich will nur zu bedenken geben heute auf
den Tag genau vor zwei Monaten hat die
Union 100.000 € von der Deutschen
Vermögensberatung bekommen weil sie
darum gebettelt haben zufällig ging es
dann bei der Geld um Übergabe ums
Provisionsverbot auf EU bevor sie jetzt
öffentlich behalten funktioniert
Meinungsbildung in der Union
das will ich vielleicht noch kurz
einwerfen ansonsten reden wir er über
einen Unternehmern
was haben sie gerade ich habe eine Frage
nein nein also sie haben
gewonnen ich würde interessieren ob Sie
ein persönliches Interesse am Erfolg von
Sebastian Böhmer oder seinem Vorhaben
vielen Dank
die nächste Frage stellt hier jung bitte
[Musik]
ich möchte noch mal nachfragen was den
Vorgang der Berufung von Sebastian
Böhmer angeht und nicht mit die konkret
verheiduk fragen sie sind ja für
Compliance zuständig
haben sie heute auch erst erfahren dass
der Staatssekretär jemand mit dem man
geschäftlich verbunden ist vorgeschlagen
hat für so ein Beirat ohne es
offenzulegen wenn man so ein Beirat ist
ja gerade gesagt wie wenig Menschen 150
des Ministerium beraten dann bringt es
ja ein renomme auch mit für die Person
und für das Unternehmen ist ja nicht zu
bestreiten er stellt sich im Dienste
Allgemeinheit das bringt auch ein
renomme mit sich ungeachtet von
finanziellen Konsequenzen hätten die
Compliance Vorschriften da nicht
verlangt das so etwas offengelegt wird
in diesem Fall haben sie es jetzt erst
erfahren gibt's seine Prüfung und würden
sie uns unterrichten wie das weitergeht
bei der Gelegenheit zum
dehnerverfahren war offen geblieben des
beamtenrechtliche Verfahren darüber
wollten sie informieren und die Frage
welche Kosten entstehen ist dadurch dass
dieses gesamte Besetzungsverfahren
wiederholt werden muss
danke die nächste Frage geht bitte
herzlichen Dank ich glaube wir haben
hier schon bewiesen dass es ein sehr
effizientes frageverfahren ist wir haben
sehr sehr viele Fragen schon beantwortet
es war übrigens auch falsch die
Darstellung am Anfang letztes Mal hätte
man vier Minuten für die Frage gehabt
jetzt macht man vier Minuten für Frage
und Antwort wenn ich mir schaue wie
lange wir schon beisammen sind dann ist
eine ganz ähnliche Größenordnung wie
beim letzten Mal ähm und tatsächlich
sind alle alle Fragen die ich stellen
wollte habe ich entweder schon gestellt
oder andere haben sie für mich gestellt
und ich erspar uns jetzt einfach doppelt
die gleiche Frage zu stellen danke danke
Frau von Shirt bitte darf ich die Zeit
mitnehmen
also ich habe Fragen zu Helga bartscht
war bis Sommer letzten Jahres bei
Blackrock und ist jetzt in der
Grundsatzabteilung ich möchte von Ihnen
wissen Herr Habeck ähm wer hat sie
angesprochen
also noch zur Zeit als sie bei Blackrock
war oder erst danach wann genau wer war
das wie ist der Kontakt hergestellt
worden zweitens möchte ich gerne wissen
mit welchen Mitarbeitern von Blackrock
sei es Vorstände aufsichtsrate sonst wer
sie in ihrer Zeit als
Wirtschaftsminister sonst noch Kontakt
gehabt haben jenseits von Herrn Merz
und dann möchte ich wissen ob Sie
ausschließen können dass Frau Bartsch
beteiligt ist an Blackrock oder Anlagen
von Blackrock und wenn sie das nicht
ausschließen können ob sie das nicht für
problematisch halten
dann möchte ich Sie fragen was sie
denken für Blackrock das wichtigste ist
der Erfolg der deutschen Wirtschaft oder
die Kapitalinteressen der Anleger und
Herrn Philipp möchte ich fragen sie
argumentieren immer mit der nicht
Befassung sie sei nicht befasst gewesen
können Sie ausschließen und ich kann die
Frage auch anders stellen profitieren
sie wirtschaftlich von den
Entscheidungen und Maßnahmen des wmdk
zur Förderung der Energiewende
danke die nächste Frage geht bitte
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender Herr
Habeck in ihren Compliance Regeln die
uns im Nachgang der gleichen Sitzung
zugestellt worden sind heißt es wie
folgt ich zitiere trennen sie strikt
Dienst und Privatleben prüfen Sie ob
Ihre Privatinteressen zu einer Kollision
mit ihren dienstlichen mit ihren
Dienstpflichten führen Zitat Ende Herr
Habeck hat Herr Philipp Strick zwischen
Dienst und Privatleben getrennt bei der
Empfehlung einer Person für ein
politisches Gremium mit der
wirtschaftlich verbunden ist
zweitens Herr Philipp gleiche Frage
haben sie strich zwischen Dienst und
Privatleben getrennt bei der Empfehlung
einer Person für ein politisches Gremium
mit der sie wirtschaftlich verbunden
sind
drittens Herr Philipp warum haben Sie
jemanden für ein politisches Gremium
empfohlen mit dem sie wirtschaftlich
verbunden sind und viertens ja weg was
ist ihre Konsequenz daraus dass ihr
Staatssekretär eine Person für ein
politisches Gremium empfohlen hat mit
der wirtschaftlich verbunden ist vielen
Dank
danke die letzte Frage geht an Herrn
lenkert bitte wenn er gerade
Vorsitzender Herr lege hat vor seiner
Einsetzung als Geschäftsführer bei der
bundeseigenen Security energy for Europe
GmbH seefe bei der besten Consulting
Group gearbeitet die besten Consulting
Group wurde vom bmwk beauftragt die
Umstrukturierung der seefe zu
analysieren ist da nicht ein
Interessenkonflikt vorhanden diese Frage
an Sie haben Minister und dann möchte
ich noch mal zu den Fonds eine Frage an
Herrn Staatssekretär Philipp Stellen
Fonds müssen ihre Beteiligung offenlegen
demzufolge wissen sie auch wenn sie
nicht in Entscheidung des Fonds
betroffen beteiligt sind in welche
Unternehmen die Fonds investiert haben
demzufolge besteht aus unserer Sicht
durchaus die Möglichkeit eines
Interessenkonfliktes das Entscheidung
die zum Beispiel ein Biotechnologie von
betreffen natürlich dann auch ihre
Unternehmensbeteiligung beeinflussen
können und gerade bei dem von meinem
Kollegen nachgefragten Fonds ist die
beteiligungsgruppe nicht so groß das
heißt Entscheidung des bmwk können für
startup s können durchaus den Wert Ihres
Fonds treffen also wir sehen sie da
nicht doch Interessen und blickt und
müssten mehr öffentlich
danke als erstes Herr Minister vielen
Dank ich habe Elke Bartsch angesprochen
und gefragt ob sie sich vorstellen kann
Abteilungsleiterin der
Grundsatzabteilung zu werden nachdem wir
das Haus umgebaut haben der ehemalige
Abteilungsleiter Philipp Steinberg hat
die Abteilung we wirtschaftssicherheit
und Energie oder wirtschaftstabilität
und Energiesicherheit übernommen das ist
die Abteilung die die
unternehmensrettung organisiert
beziehungsweise die ganzen Struktur
jetzt auch Wasserstoff Infrastruktur
baut dadurch ist die Abteilungsleitung 1
frei geworden und ich die sie wissen das
ist die alte würdigste Abteilung ohne
den anderen Kollegen zu nahe zu treten
und Wirtschaftsministerium wo die
grundsatzpolitik gemacht wird ich habe
eine Ökonomen gesucht das ist mit
kleinen gesprochen ich versuche so gut
wie es geht das Haus paritätisch
aufzustellen
außerdem suchte ich jemand der
Erfahrung als Volkswirtin hat und
Nachhaltigkeitskriterien die ja wichtig
sind für die deutschen Wirtschaft
mitgebracht hat so dass ich mit Elke
Bart wann genau weiß ich nicht mehr aber
vielleicht ungefähr einen Monat oder
zwei Monate vor ihrer Berufung den
Kontakt aufgenommen habe mit ihr
gesprochen habe ob Sie sich das
vorstellen kann und nach Überlegungszeit
ist sie dann zu uns gekommen
zu den Vermögensverhältnissen
verärgerbarsch kann ich mich nicht
äußern habe ich keine Kenntnisse drüber
dann würde ich einen ein Konflikt das
Posten Consulting Group das Ministerium
beraten hat kann ich jetzt nicht
erkennen wo soll der herkommen wo du
philipp ist nicht Mitglied der basteln
Consulting Group und Helga Barsch auch
nicht
erlege ist Geschäftsführer von Seefeld
und überhaupt aus dem Concealer und wo
ist der Compliance Konflikt
ich meine es ganz ernst also wenn wenn
sie wenn sie unterstellen dass Leute die
irgendwo gearbeitet haben
weitere Aufträge quasi unmöglich machen
wo soll das hinführen also was ist die
Unterstellung da drin ich verstehe es in
dieser Stelle wirklich nicht ich kann
jedenfalls kein Konflikt dort erkennen
und ich will noch einmal wobei die Frage
an oder Philipp geht ich glaube ich
wiederhole mich aber zum nächsten Male
darauf hinweisen ja in Fonds das war
mein Eingang steht Moment sind Aktien
wir haben den Dax vor besprochen und
ganz viele Entscheidungen die wir alle
hier treffen werden in irgendeiner Form
DAX Unternehmen betreffen es mag
spezifische Entscheidungen geben ich
habe das Beispiel Gesundheitswirtschaft
genannt oder Landwirtschaft oder
Rüstungsindustrie wo dann unmittelbare
Entscheidungen getroffen werden die dann
möglicherweise sehr sehr mittelbar auf
die auf die
Fonds würden trotzdem werden sie
getroffen und es gibt keine Vorschrift
keine compliancevorschrift auch nicht
die strengvorschriften des BMF die sagen
deswegen muss man entweder seine Fonds
verkaufen oder sie öffentlich machen
oder immer kontrollieren
diese Debatte kann geführt werden aber
dann meine ich muss sie geführt werden
auch von den finalen
Entscheidungsträgern das ist da
parlamentarische Raum also fragen Sie
sich ob sie wissen wenn Sie eine
Lebensversicherung halten welche Anteile
in der Lebensversicherung drin sind
fragen Sie sich ob ich will es nicht
relikalisieren aber ob alle Leute die
Riester Verträge geschlossen haben
wissen was in ihren Riester Verträgen
sind fragen Sie sich ob Sie genau wissen
welche Anteile in ihren Fonds sind bevor
wir in die nächste Sitzung gehen und
haben sie sich gefragt welche
Unternehmen besonders vom Rettungsschirm
Gas oder Strompreis Bremsen
profitieren ich finde es sind
berechtigte Fragen ja man darf sich
stellen aber dann nicht nur an Udo
Philipp sondern an alle wenn wir die
Regeln strenger machen wollen dann noch
einmal stehe ich dafür bereit ich finde
sogar dass die Frage von Fonds fast weil
diese passive Management also dritte
verwalten die Fonds weniger interessant
sind als vielleicht
direkte Vermögensverhältnisse oder
Schuldverhältnisse das wäre ja mal
interessant wer hat wie viel Kredite
unmöglicherweise bei Privatpersonen und
leitet das Handeln wenn der Deutsche
Bundestag das für sich veröffentlichen
möchte oder er möchte dass es die
Regierung tut also alle Minister bevor
sie erst einmal Minister werden oder
Staatssekretäre oder Abteilungsleiter
ziehen Sie die Grenze wo Sie wollen erst
einmal sagen müssen haben sie ihr Haus
abbezahlt wie viel Kredit haben sie und
so weiter das finde ich ebenfalls
relevante Fragen ich will darauf hinaus
dass wir das ist kein Ende gibt wenn man
diese Fragen stellt aber andere Länder
machen es anders Frankreich
beispielsweise fordert von seiner
Regierungsmitglieder dass sie die
Eigentumsverhältnisse auflegen und es
gibt eine Kommission die darüber macht
wir können uns diese Fragen stellen
die stoßen an andere Rechte an
Beteiligungsrechte an individuelle
Freiheitsrechte natürlich aber man darf
diese Fragen stellen nur dann allen und
gleiches Recht für alle an der Stelle
vielen Dank
so dann habe ich ein Interesse am Erfolg
von
first Momentum Ventures ich habe das ja
mehrfach gesagt was Momentum Ventures
ist der erste studentische
Manager capital ich würde mich wirklich
sehr freuen wenn es gelingen würde dass
Studenten anderen Studenten unter die
Arme greifen können weil es weil es
meiner Meinung nach nicht angehen kann
dass das ähm Studenten wenn sie sich
selbstständig machen auf ein reiches
Elternhaus angewiesen sind insofern habe
ich ein Glas Interesse außerdem bin ich
in dem Fall investiert das heißt ich
habe auch ein Interesse daran dass der
Form nicht irgendwie pleite geht gibt es
ein eine Connex dazu zwischen einer
Mitgliedschaft im Beirat junge digitale
Wirtschaft und der Frage wie sich die
ich weiß nicht wie viele ist sind nicht
gezählt aber es werden sicherlich
mindestens 20 sein Unternehmen die dort
in der in dem vorderen sind ob die sich
dann dadurch besser entwickeln diesen
Konnex sehe ich nicht und deswegen sehe
ich auch kein Interessenskonflikt so
dann profitieren wir von der
Energiewende alle die wir hier sitzen
profitieren hoffentlich von der
Energiewende und alle die irgendwelche
Aktien haben in ihren Depots die die die
sich damit beschäftigen profitieren
vielleicht auch davon die Frage ob ich
irgendwo ähm
dienstliches und privates Interesse
trenne da kann ich klar mit ja
beantworten die
letzte Frage noch mal das wiederhole ich
mich noch mal immer wieder es ist in der
Tat richtig ich kann nach setzt die
Frage von
zwei Lenker die sie diesmal gestellt hat
die ich könnte nachschauen was was in
den Fonds drin ist ich gebe aber gerne
zu dass ich das bislang nicht gemacht
habe ja das ich habe jetzt anlässig
dieser Geschichten das erste Mal diese
Sachen aufgemacht aber ich habe nichts
systematisch das untersucht und es hat
mich bislang auch nie interessiert was
da drin ist und wie ich ihm sagte das
hat der Minister mehrfach gesagt ich
habe es mehrfach gesagt die Frage stellt
sich nicht ja die leitet kein
interessens Konflikt her ja außer man
diskutiert so wie äh der Minister das
gerade gesagt hat dass man vielleicht
irgendwo gesellschaftlich sich anders
aufstellen sollte eine andere Kultur
haben sollte
Herr Jung sie haben mich auch gefragt in
meiner Rolle als amtschefin zum Thema
Beirat junge digitale Wirtschaft ich
möchte das ausdrücklich sagen wir haben
uns ja hier jetzt aufgrund der Fragen
auch sehr viel Mühe gegeben die Rolle
des Beirats seiner Aufgabe seine
Funktion und auch seine Größe
ausführlich darzustellen und ich muss
Ihnen sagen dass ich vor dem Hintergrund
des hier dargestellten nicht erkennen
kann dass es dort wonach sie mich
gefragt haben eine Compliance
Angelegenheit ist die eine
Interessenkollision von Herrn Philipp
bedeuten könnte da habe ich eine klare
Auffassung vor dem Hintergrund der
Beantwortung und der Darstellung der
Sachlage zweite Frage Beamten auch
gefragt ob sie schon vor heute wussten
dass er ihn vorgeschlagen hat aber die
geschäftliche Verbindung nicht offen
gelegt hat die die ganze Fragestellung
dieses Hintergrund ist mir in der
Vorbereitung der ganzen Thematik für
diese Sitzung erst bekannt geworden
ich halte es ausdrücklich für
unproblematische und es ist ja auch gut
wenn man da noch mal hinguckt es ist ja
auch hier öffentliche Sitzung dass man
noch mal genau erklärt was ist das und
da habe ich eine Auffassung dass das
keine Compliance Angelegenheit und einen
äh in ein interessenkollisionspunkt sein
würde und könnte
zweiter Punkt aber zum
beamtenrechtlichen Verfahren und der
Prüfung was den Staatssekretär Patrick
reichen angeht es ist so dass die
Prüfung des Sachverhalts läuft und das
Verfahren betrieben wird aber ich habe
schon gesagt dass auch in der letzten
Sitzung das bmwk grundsätzlich zu
Einzelheiten eines solchen Verfahrens
aus Personen Datenschutzgründen keine
bestellt keine Bestellung beziehen darf
und deswegen werde ich auch zum weiteren
Verlauf des Verfahrens sowieso nicht so
inhaltlichen Aspekten aus eben diesen
Gründen hier Stellung nehmen können
meine Frage war noch offen Unmut bei
ihnen sie haben die Möglichkeit doch mit
kurz nachzufragen ist keine Nachfrage es
ist nur die Wiederholung der gleichen
Frage und die richtete
mitzuteilen ob er jenseits von Herrn
märz und Frau Bartsch er oder in seinem
Hause Kontakt hatte mit Blackrock
Mitarbeitern gehabt hat geht wieder Art
Vorstände aufsichtsrate sonst wer über
Themen wird das Pulli Wirtschaft und
Energiepolitik ich möchte wissen wie
tief sozusagen sie mit Blackrock in
Verbindung sind keine keine Kontakte
außer der ehemaligen Massage Ökonomen zu
Blackrock und Friedrich Merz
und damit
der Kollege Wenzel
sehr geehrter Abgeordnete sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren es war noch die Frage
offen von Herrn Jung nach den Kosten der
der des der Neuaufsetzung des Verfahrens
bei der Dehner und da dazu kann ich
sagen dass der Aufsichtsrat sich hier
auf eine einvernehmliche Aufhebung des
Vertrages mit Herrn Schäfer verständigt
hat wegen der Beendigung des Vertrags
und dem damit verbundenen Verlust des
Arbeitsplatzes hat die Gesellschaft herr
Schäfer eine der Sache und Rechtslage
angemessene Abfindung Angeboten davon
hat das ist nicht
ausverhandelt worden weil Herr Schäfer
darauf verzichtet hat und geltend
gemacht hat dass er keine
Arbeitsleistung erbringen kann und
deshalb auch keine Abfindung haben
wollte
es gab eine gibt nur eine Verständigung
über die
Rechtsanwaltskosten und da ist aber noch
keine Abrechnung erfolgt Rechtsanwalts
und Fremdkosten was da in Rechnung
gestellt wird wissen wir noch nicht die
Gesamtkosten nach denen sie gefragt
haben ergeben sich auch erst dann wenn
wir wissen zu welchem Zeitpunkt die neue
Person am Ende auch den die Arbeit
aufnehmen kann wenn da zwischen dem
ursprünglich angepeilten Datum
01.07
und dem dann erfolgt der dann
erfolgenden Arbeitsaufnahme ein zwei
oder drei Monate liegen dann wird die
Gesellschaft hier unterm Strich
möglicherweise überhaupt keine
Mehrkosten haben und
das ganze Verfahren muss doch wiederholt
werden sind Verfahren kostet doch Geld
mit Personalagentur und vielem mehr
ja genau die zum einen arbeiten die
Aufsichtsratsmitglieder alle
ehrenamtlich da kriegt niemand Geld
natürlich wird Personal von der
Beteiligungsverwaltung in Anspruch
genommen und die
Agentur wird
voraussichtlich
15.000 Euro erhalten und die
Anzeigenkosten für die Stellenanzeige
kommen dazu aber wie gesagt wenn wir
eine Vakanz von drei Monaten hätten zum
Beispiel was nicht unwahrscheinlich ist
weil solche hochqualifizierte Leute in
der Regel aus dem Arbeitsverhältnis
kommen und nicht arbeitslos sind dann
wird trotzdem unterm Strich
eine sehr geringe oder sogar eine
negative Summe stehen
okay ich denke damit sind wir am Ende
unserer heutigen Gespräch
unter Punkt Verschiedenes nur ganz kurz
also anfänglich der sehr hektisch
gehäuseten Bedenken möchte mich erstmal
bedanken dass das so fair verlaufen ist
und ich finde so wie wir das jetzt
organisiert haben hat es dem Sachverhalt
der Aufdeckung und Erklärung sicherlich
sagt die nicht geholfen und beigetragen
und dafür herzlichen Dank okay ich will
noch mal darauf hinweisen ich würde mal
darauf hinweisen dass ich auch Falle
dass es ordentlich über die Bühne ging
was wir gemacht haben die Bewertung
allerdings die wird natürlich die
Öffentlichkeit auch für sich vornehmen
die wird natürlich auch bewerten welche
Aussagen gekommen sind und wie sie denn
das jeweils sieht und das ist auch ihr
gutes Recht und genauso wird es
natürlich auch die Abgeordneten machen
ich hoffe allerdings dass wir nicht in
eine Situation geraten wo man bei der
letzten Anhörung waren das dann hinter
dir doch einiges anders war nicht vom
Inhalt hier sondern von dem Ergebnis
also wir sind in der Sitzung noch
vermutet haben ich bedanke mich dass sie
anwesend waren
Minister danke Ihnen dass Sie uns zur
Verfügung stand ich bedanke mich für die
Fragestellungen und ich bedanke mich
dafür dass das diszipiert und sauber
über die Bühne gehen recht herzlichen
Dank die Sitzung ist damit geschlossen
so meine Damen und Herren was eine
komplizierte Veranstaltung meine Damen
und Herren aber eine spannende also
ordnen wir das ganze gerne noch einmal
es steht der Vorwürfe im Raum das im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
Interessenkonflikte bestanden oder auch
noch bestehen ein Staatssekretär Patrick
reichen hat darüber schon seinen Job
verloren auch wenn eine irgendwie
geartete Schuld ja noch nicht bewiesen
ist ein anderer Staatssekretär des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers Robert Habeck
nämlich Udo Philipp der steht jetzt auch
am Pranger vor allem der Opposition im
Bundestag er sei an der Berufung eines
Beraters beteiligt gewesen in dessen
Fonds er vorher Geld investiert hatte
darüber müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch
mal sprechen mit Professor Uwe juhn
Politikwissenschaftler der Universität
Trier
guten Tag Herr Bauer und sie haben sich
das alle mit uns gemeinsam reingezogen
haben der Staatssekretär Philipp und der
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck die Bedenken
und die Vorwürfe vor allem aus der
Opposition aus ihrer Sicht zerstreut
zerstreut kann man nicht sagen sie
wussten halt auch einräumen dass es da
Verbindungslinien gibt insbesondere zu
Herrn Böhmer und damit eben zur jungen
digitalen Wirtschaft also den Beirat und
dementsprechenden Fond
das wurde hier deutlich dass Herr
Philipp mit diesem vor verbunden ist und
er allerdings dann zurückweisen konnte
dass das gegen die Regeln verstößt gegen
die sogenannten Compliance Regeln
sondern dass es diesen entspricht und
von daher wurde manches bestätigt und
man kann sagen am Ende ist relativ wenig
dabei rausgekommen die Bewertung
allerdings das hat er ernst der
Vorsitzende des Klima Ausschuss ist ja
jetzt noch mal deutlich gemacht dürfte
daran liegen dass im
Wirtschaftsministerium dann doch die
eine oder andere Personalie sehr locker
vergeben wird und dass man den
Wirtschaftsministerium sicherlich dann
in Zukunft etwas vorsichtiger bei der
Besetzung vieler Ämter und auch von
beiratspositionen agieren wird ich finde
das spannende Herr Professor juhn an
dieser Übertragung die wir jetzt hier
hatten ist ja auch dass wir alle als
ZuschauerInnen aber auch als
Gebührenzahler als Menschen hier in
Deutschland ein Einblick bekommen eben
auch wie Politik am Ende auch
funktioniert jetzt haben sie eben gesagt
das wird locker Posten würden aus ihrer
Sicht im Wirtschaftsministerium locker
vergeben was haben sie damit gemeint
ich meinte eben dass man es kam dann zu
einem Brainstorming wie man
beiratspositionen besetzt oder wurde ja
gesagt da hätte er habe ich dann einen
Vorschlag gehabt und dann wurde kurz
darüber nachgedacht wer könnte das sein
und dann wurden wohl zwei Namen konkret
vom Staatssekretär vorgeschlagen und der
wurde dann benannt das heißt es kam da
jetzt nicht zu irgendwelchen längeren
auswahlprozessen zu längeren Gesprächen
nach welchen Kriterien man solche
beiratspositionen besetzt das war damit
nur erstmal gemeint und ist damit zum
Ausdruck gebracht hat Philipp ja
argumentiert also der Staatssekretär im
Wirtschaftsministerium er habe Gelder
seine eigenen privaten Gelder über Fonds
oder über Banken investiert und er habe
gar nicht gewusst was dann die
tatsächlich davon kaufen ist diese
Argumentation aus ihrer Sicht stimmig um
das abzuschließen
naja es ist sowohl tatsächlich so dass
man nicht unbedingt weiß oder wissen
muss wie Vermögensverwalter und das sind
Banken das sind dann auch andere
Vermögensverwalter das Geld anlegen in
welche Firmen das investiert ist und
klar der Philipp dann eben gesagt er
kümmert sich da jetzt nicht so um die um
das einzelmanagement dieses Vermögens
und das wird ihm jedenfalls schwer
nachzuweisen sein dass er hier nicht die
Wahrheit gesagt hat sondern das könnte
durchaus stimmt genau das ist so kenne
ich das auch tatsächlich man gibt der
Bank einen Auftrag und die Bank
investiert das normalerweise meine Frage
an sie war da eher ob das tatsächlich
dann auch den Vorwurf ausräumt oder
nicht vertiefe das ganze noch mal meine
Frage oder ob dann trotzdem ein
geschmeckle bleibt
naja das hat ja Robert Habeck am Anfang
deutlich gemacht das ist nicht einfach
war jemanden aus der Privatwirtschaft zu
gewinnen der eben im Finanzmarkt eine
große Rolle gespielt hat eine nicht
unwichtige Rolle und der in diesen
Finanzmarktgeschäften auch immer noch
tätig ist und dass da da das eine oder
andere möglicherweise kritisiert wird
skeptisch hinterfragt wird dessen war
man sich bewusst aber offenkundig
jedenfalls so der aktuelle Stand der
Dinge hat hat man nicht gegen die im
Wirtschaftsministerium bestehenden
Compliance Regeln verstoßen ich finde
das ist auch eine Qualität von dieser
Übertragung auch unsere Übertragung
jetzt gewesen dass wir darüber jetzt
eben auch so intensiv diskutieren eben
auch mal über ich sag mal die
Hintergründe von Politik die wir häufig
als Menschen Bürger dieses Landes gar
nicht so mitbekommen ein weiterer Punkt
dazu war heute auch das Prozedere die
Mehrheit der Regierung hat vor dieser
Sitzung bestimmt dass nur eine Minute
pro Frage möglich war und nicht der
direkt darauf geantwortet werden dürfte
so wie das noch vor einer Woche in der
letzten Sitzung war die Opposition hat
das sehr stark kritisiert wer hat da
recht aus ihrer Sicht
es ist wohl so dass bei den Sitzungen
des Wirtschaftsausschusses dieses
Verfahren was wir heute erlebt haben die
gängige Praxis ist und dass man eben
hier gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit dieses
gängige Verfahren wieder anwenden wollte
und kein anderes Verfahren wie man es
beim letzten Mal dann wohl vorgesehen
hatte und von daher kann man natürlich
sagen aber beim letzten mal an etwas
tiefer gehendes Verfahren was die
Möglichkeiten der Fragestellung betrifft
im Gegensatz zu heutigen angewandt
worden ist haben beide Seiten irgendwo
recht man hat jetzt ein gängiges
Verfahren gewählt aber beim letzten mal
ein anderes und am Ende muss man aber
sagen es ist ähm und da würde ich dem
Herrn Westfall recht geben es wurden
doch alle Fragen wesentlich beantwortet
und die beiden Vorsitzenden haben dann
auch immer dafür Sorge getragen dass
jetzt keine Frage völlig unbeantwortet
blieb also ich will damit sagen dass das
prozedurale am Ende dann doch
unerheblich war und trotzdem war es eine
sehr sehr intensive Ausschusssitzung ich
hatte das Gefühl alle wissen das Kameras
und eben auch wir als Fernsehen bei
Phoenix dabei sind und und gingster aus
ihrer Sicht der Opposition auch darum
Robert Habeck weiter in der Schusslinie
zu halten auch vor dem Hintergrund der
Diskussion um ein neues heizungsgesetz
es war sicherlich erkennbar dass von
Seiten der Opposition nun der
Wirtschaftsminister auch persönlich hier
kritisiert werden sollte dass man eben
versuchen wollte ihnen in
öffentlichkeitswirksam zu kontrollieren
und mit seiner Kritik hier auch dann
entsprechend oder mit ihrer Kritik die
Opposition damit auch den Führungsstil
des Wirtschaftsministers attackieren
wollte dennoch blieb alles sachlich und
man kann sagen man hat auch in keinster
Weise hier die Sache verlassen und das
Gebäude Energiegesetz der Bauer was sie
gerade angesprochen haben kam dann ja
auch ein an keiner Stelle er ernsthaft
zur Sprache es wurde lediglich von den
Grünen selbst mal thematisiert indem es
eben die grüne Vertreterin selbst
gefragt hatte ob denn mit der
Neubesetzung des Staatssekretärs hier im
Wirtschaftsministerium alles gut sei mit
Blick auf die Durchsetzung dieses
Gesetzes im Ministerium selbst was dann
her sind ja bestätigen konnte überhaupt
viel auf dass die Grünen sehr freundlich
mit ihrem Minister umging auch mit ihrem
Staatssekretär während alle anderen doch
eher kritisch waren insbesondere nicht
nur die Opposition sondern ist viel auch
auf dass die FDP-Abgeordneten kritische
Fragen Richtung Wirtschaftsministerium
stellten Herr Professor Höhn ich habe da
fast ein bisschen um meinen Job
gefürchtet so kritisch haben wir
teilweise die Abgeordneten nachgefragt
und gut zugehört werde ich mir merken
und vielleicht das nächste Mal wenn ich
in Berlin bin mal als Gast zu so einer
Ausschusssitzung gehen vielen dank ihnen
Professor Uwe
jugendpolitikwissenschaftler der Uni
Trier für die Einordnung
ich danke Ihnen aber so meine Damen und
Herren und damit gehen wir rüber in den
Bundestag zu meinem Kollegen er hat
schärfer denn dort läuft die Befragung
der Bundesregierung und heute Nachmittag
ist ja dann tatsächlich wieder das
heizungsgesetz also das der Entwurf zum
Gebäude Energiegesetz Thema auf Antrag
der Unionsfraktion es ist ein intensiver
Tag für sie er hat schärfer viel Spaß
uns allen damit